bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat au sommaire de votre
après-midi dans un instant vous allez
suivre l'audition de jean- Leonetti et
Alain Cless sur la fin de vie ils
étaient auditionnés ce matin par la
commission des affaires sociales et à
19h vous retrouvez votre journal
présenté par Delphine Girard votre
journal Le 24h Sénat mais d'abord à la
une de l'actualité parlementaire la
réforme du droit d'asile à l'unanimité
la commission des Lois du Sénat vient de
demander le report de ce texte de
l'examen de ce texte en séance il devait
arriver en séance publique devant les
sénateurs le 5 mai prochain cette
demande intervient dans un contexte
quelque peu polémique puisqu' hier un
rapport de la Cour des comptes à fuité
un rapport qui dénonce le coût
faramineux de cette politique près de 2
milliards d'euros annuel et surtout une
politique qui part qui est au bord de
l'embolie je cite alors pourquoi cette
demande de report des sénateurs on
écoute François Noël buffet rapporteur
UMP de ce texte au Sénat et à la faveur
du rapport provisoire de la Cour des
comptes qui a été rendu publique mardi
dernier il m'est apparu utile de pouvoir
auditionner les magistrats et en savoir
plus sur ce qu'ils disent sur ce qu'ils
prétendent et pour PIR nourir le rapport
et avoir un rapport parfaitement complet
dans l'actualité parlementaire également
cet amendement surprise d'Emmanuel
Macron le ministre de l'Économie a
déposé lui-même une mesure qui prévoit
de réduire l'impôt sur les sociétés de
2,5 milliards d'euros en les incitant à
investir il était encore en commission
il y a quelques instants comme vous
pouvez le voir sur ces images la mesure
si elle est votée s'appliquerait d'avril
2015 à avril 2016 un coup de pouce
fiscal annoncé par Manuel Vals la
semaine dernière le ministre a voulu
profiter du travail parlementaire pour
faire adopter cette mesure on écoute
Emmanuel Macron ministre de l'économie
au micro de Nathalie
guilloard un amendement au dernier
moment c'était simplement le Premier
ministre a fait la semaine dernière des
annonces très précises et il estta
important de les traduire le plus vite
possible dans la loi ce qui était notre
souhait et ce que nos concitoyens
attendent pour leur donner une pleine
visibilité c'est l'objet de cet
amendement d'accord et du coup dedans
qu'est-ce qu'il y a exactement
exactement ce que le premier ministre a
annoncé semaine dernière un
suramortissement de 40 % pour tout
investissement productif dans les
entreprises françaises d'accord merci
beaucoup merci à vous merci il y a
finalement eu deux rapports deux
propositions des présidents du Sénat et
de l'Assemblée nationale sur
l'engagement républicain ce matin Gérard
Larcher et Claude Bartolone ont remis
ensemble leur proposition au président
de la République de propositions très
distincte sur l'engagement républicain
François Hollande leur avait confié
cette mission au lendemain des attentats
meurtriers de janvier dernier mais dès
la fin janvier un quakque les deux
hommes fâchés avaient décidé de
travailler chacun de leur côté plus
d'informations sur le contenu de ces
rapports dans votre édition de 19h et
puis un guide de bonnes pratiques et de
nouvelles règles pour l'IRFM l'indemnité
représentative des frais de mandat c'est
ce qui c'est ce qui a décidé ce matin le
bureau du Sénat il ne sera par exemple
plus possible d'acheter sa permanence
parlementaire avec cette indemnité les
sénateurs poursuivent donc le grand
chantier de la réforme du Sénat entamé
par Gérard Larcher on écoute à ce sujet
Françoise Cartron vice-présidente du
bureau du Sénat au micro de Louis cbille
on l'a vu par rapport à à des
problématiques qui sont sorties autour
de l'Assemblée nationale le financement
de l'achat de permanence ou autrre donc
la pose question et donc désormais ça ne
sera plus possible que les prêts que
l'on a pu que les uns et les autres
aurait pu souscrire et dont l'échéancier
était imputé sur le RFM ce n'est plus
possible désormais il faut avoir un
compte séparé si on l'achète et on
nachète pas cette permanence ou ce local
avec
l'IRFM et le bureau du Sénat a également
désigné le nouveau président de Public
Sénat c'est donc Emmanuel Kessler chef
du pôle économie à LCI et ancien
journaliste de Public Sénat qui a été
désigné il succédera à l'actuel
président Gilles Leclerc le premier juin
prochain autre temps fort de l'actualité
au Sénat la levée d'immunité
parlementaire d'ivon Collin le sénateur
radical de gauche du Tarne et Garon est
visé par une enquête pour corruption il
avait lui-même demandé cette levée
d'immunité au bureau du Sénat et puis je
vous le disais en titre la commission
des affaires sociales auditionnée ce
matin deux députés jean-léonetti et
Alain claess sur leur proposition de loi
sur la fin de vie un texte adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale en première
lecture le 10 17 mars dernier parmi les
mesures phares proposées par les deux
députés les directives anticipées qui
permettent aux patients de faire
connaître à leurs proches et à leurs
médecins la manière dont ils souhaitent
terminer leur vie et puis l'autre mesure
phare c'est bien sûr la sédation
profonde jusqu'au décès pour les malades
en phase terminale on découvre tout de
suite cette audition donc je vous
remercie et je remercie en particulier
Alain clè et Jean Leonetti d'avoir bien
voulu venir nous présentai ce matin leur
proposition de loi créant de nouveaux
droits en faveur des malades et des
personnes en fin de vie ces nouveaux
droit vous le savez s'appuie euh sur la
notion de sédation profonde et continue
accompagnant l'arrêt des traitements
jusqu'au décès mais aussi sur un
renforcement des directives
anticipées celle-ci s'imposerait au
médecins sauf dans des cas limités et
obéirit à des modèles type destiné à les
rendre plus
opérationnel la proposition de loi a été
déposée le 21 janvier dernier dans la
foulée des conclusions de Alain Cless et
jean- Leonetti ceuxci les avaient
remises au Premier ministre sur la
mission que celui-ci leur avait confié
elle a été adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale le 17 mars le calendrier de
discussion au Sénat prévoit un examen en
commission à la fin du mois de mai mais
si le rapporteur Gérard et Michel Amiel
et en séance publique vers la mi-juin il
m'a paru donc important au moment où
débutent nos travaux sur ce texte que
nos deux collègues qui l'ont élaboré
puissent nous rappeler le cadre de leur
démarche les
objectifs poursuivis par la proposition
doit et les modifications qu'elle va
entraîner par rapport à la législation
actuelle mais aussi par rapport aux
pratiqu et aux situations concrètes
constaté pour les malades en fin de vie
à l'Assemblée nationale une trentaine
d'amendements ont été adopté au stade de
la Commission et une vingtaine au stade
de la séance publique je souhaiterais
également qu'in clè et Jean Leonetti
puissent évoquer les points qui ont fait
débat et les modifications qui ont été
apportés par rapport au texte initial
qu'ils avaient déposé et je leur laisse
immédiatement la parole à afin que
chacun puisse ensuite chacun d'entre
vous puisse ensuite après nos
rapporteurs leur poser les questions qu'
désir je vous laisse la parole messieurs
an
d'abord je vrais tout d'abord monsieur
le Président vous vous remercier de nous
accueillir au Sénat je crois que cette
relation entre nos deux assemblées est
essentielle sur un sujet
comme celui-là j'is dire il faudrait il
faut une
coproduction je voudrais très rapidement
pour laisser la place au débat et que
jeanetti puisse s'exprimer sur les
articles principaux vous rappelez le le
contexte de notre
travail vous savez que lors de la
campagne présidentielle
François Hollande avait pris un
engagement je crois qu'il est pas
inutile de le rappeler les terme de cet
engagement l'engagement était le suivant
toute personne majeure en phase avancée
ou terminale d'une maladie incurable
provoquant une souffrance physique ou
psychique insupportable et qui peut être
apaisé puisse demander dans les
condition précises et strictes à
bénéficier d'une assistance médicalisée
pour terminer sa vie dans la dignité
voilà les propos du président de la
République suite à cela et suite à
l'élection présidentielle euh vous le
savez le président de la République a
confié au professeur
siik une mission
pour faire ce que j'allais ce que je
peux appeler un état des
lieux je crois que lorsqu'on relit le le
le le le rapport
SICAR
je crois qu'on peut dire qu'il
est en quelque sorte
accablant on meurt mal en France dans de
mauvaises conditions et c'est je
crois cette idée qui a
organisé tous nos débats et nos
réflexions avec Jean par la suite j'ai
pas besoin de rappeler le constat que
fait le rapport SICAR vous les
connaissez
parfaitement
inégalité
territoriale
inégalité dans les lieux même de fin de
vie peu de soins palliatifs ou pas du
tout dans les
épales à
domicile des soins palliatifs implantés
très inégalement dans les hôpitaux CHU
et un chiffre qui est quand même
significatif 51 % des décès ont lieu aux
urgences faut savoir que mais vous le
savez sur vos territoire vous pouvez le
constater j'allais dire pratiquement
chaque
semaine le vendredi soir dans une épal à
20h il y a plus
d'infirmière rarement un médecin
référence et si il y a la moindre
difficulté la personne est transférée
aux
urgences concernant euh les soins
palliatifs euh de déficit tout d'abord
en terme de
formation là encore vous je ne vous
apprendrai rien euh la culture
palliative est peu ou pas enseignée dans
les études de
médecine il y a véritablement une
coupure entre la démarche curative et
palliative il faut bien reconnaître que
les soins palliatifs interviennent
toujours au bout de la
vie
j'ajoute que lorsqu'on veut rentrer dans
les détails les gens l'avaent fait
remarquer dès le début de notre mission
quand on regarde la T2A pour rentrer un
peu dans les techniques on voit bien que
les soins palliatifs il devrait y avoir
à
revisiter cette tarification à
l'activité sur les soins palliatif donc
il y a véritablement en besoin en France
d'une formation sur les soins palliatifs
et deuxièmement que ces soins palliatifs
soient beaucoup plus développés qu'ils
ne le sont
aujourd'hui
notre le rapport
SICAR a fait l'objet ensuite de toute
une série de d'analyses de Comité
consultatif national d'éthique je crois
que le Sénat est représenté par le au
Comité consultatif national d'éthique a
rendu son
rapport même constat un certain nombre
de préconisations sur lesquelles on
pourra revenir et ensuite chose nouvell
mais qui était qui est lié aux avancées
de la loi bioéthique qu'on avait suivi à
l'Assemblée avec
Jean il y a eu une consultation
citoyenne qui a été coordonné par le
Comité consultatif national
d'éthique là aussi des conclusions et un
certain
nombre de préconisations tout cela fait
l'objet d'un rapport du Comité
consultative national d'éthique à ne pas
confondre avec son avis un rapport qui
faisait la synthèse de l'ensemble de ces
sujets et est venu ensuite la lre de
mission la lette de mission
du Premier ministre qui nous a été
adressé en en
juin qui disait la chose suivante c'est
important peut-être de la rappeler parce
que ça fixe le
cadre du travail que nous avons
réalisé avec jeens demande de
proposition dans trois directions
développement de la médecine palliative
y compris de la formation initiale des
professionnels de santé une meilleure
organisation du recueil et de la prise
en compte des directives anticip en leur
conférant un caractère contraignant et
la définition des conditions et des
circonstances précises dans lesquelles
l'apaisement des souffrances peut
conduire à abrager la vie dans le
respect de la personne voilà la lettre
de mission du Premier
ministre suite à cela nous sommes mis au
travail et euh nous avons euh réalisé
une quarantaine
d'audition sous réserve d'inventaire je
ne crois pas que nous avons oublié tel
ou tel association représentants je
crois que nous avons eu la volonté de
pouvoir auditionner l'ensemble euh des
acteurs euh euh concernant euh
la fin de vie et les droits des
malades peut-être pour bien comprendre
notre démarche je voudrais vous rappeler
un état d'esprit notre état d'esprit
dans ce travail nous ne partions pas de
rien il y avait la loi dit Leonetti
2005 qui a été une avance c'est
importante
et qui a en
particulier traiter ce sujet
important de l'achartement
thérapeutique cette loi l'odti
s'inscrivait dans une loi qui avait été
votée préalablement qu'on a appelé la
loi
couchner sur le droit des malades en
2002 et avant ces lois il y a eu des
textes inscrivant comme priorité des
soins
palliatifs
et ce qui est important quand je regarde
avec le recul l'ensemble de C texte
c'est
combien nos deux assemblées le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale ont contribué et
ont participé ensemble sur tous ces
sujets c'est pour ça que je vous le moi
je suis très très heureux d'être avec
vous avec vous ce matin et encore merci
d'avoir pris cette
initiative la loi la proposition de loi
que nous avons déposé le 21 janvier avec
Jean
lenetti était quelque part dans le
prolongement de ce travail législatif
qui a été réalisé depuis 10 ans je crois
que ça serait absurde de vouloir
procéder par rupture sur un sujet comme
cela le
temps
l'expérience parfois est plus utile que
toute autre chose pour faire évoluer nos
textes je crois qu'il faut être sur ce
sujet d'une très grande modestie donc
moi je le dis
clairement la proposition de loi queons
fait adopter l'Assemblée nationale n'est
pas en rupture avec le travail qui avait
été fait avant je le dis d'autant plus
facilement qu'en 2005 au nom du groupe
socialiste
j'avais fait d'explication de vote sur
la loi le neti et nous
avions appelé à voter pour ce texte qui
avait été travaillé par gens mais
d'autres personnalités je pense
particulier à Gath engor qui est
aujourd'hui dans dans votre dans votre
maison vous allez me dire quels ont été
les les sujets de débat à l'Assemblée
nationale et laisserai gens ensuite
parler du contenu bah vous les
connaissez
euh il y a
eu une série de collègues H qui nous ont
dit à travers leur amendement il n'y a
rien à
changer euh euh ne bougeons pas la loi
ça a été quelque chose de qui a étit
présent dans l'hémicycle et qui a fait
l'objet de quelques heures de débat et
puis il y a
eu d'autres amendements une autre
position euh vous n'allez pas
suffisamment loin
euh euh et ça a été les propositions euh
de l'acte létal l'euthanasie
ou le suicide
assisté et par rapport à
c'est courant qui existait à l'Assemblée
nationale nous avons tenu bon sur nos
propositions avons tenu bon sur nos
propositions
pour deux raisons
essentielles la première raison c'était
de répondre
précisément à la fois à la demande du
Premier ministre qui fixa un cadre très
précis et j' y reviendra et à
l'engagement du président de la
République
et la deuxième
raison qui
est à mal avis aussi
importante c'est c'était sur un débat de
société aussi important non pas trouver
je ne sais je ne sais quel consensus le
mot n'aurait aucun na aucun intérêt mais
une
convergence une convergence qui permet
de dépasser un certain
nombre un certain nombre de différence
et j'ajoute qui permet de régler un
grand nombre de cas aujourd'hui concret
en France car au bout du compte au bout
du compte ce que notre mission notre
devoir en tant que législateur c'est
faire en sorte que ce mal mourir en
France puisse véritablement reculer
ilajoute un dernier point de deux
derniers
points cette proposition de loi n'est
absolument pas en contre adiction avec
le développement des soins palliatifs
j'allais dire que c'est un prolongement
logique des soins palliatifs vouloir
opposer de nouveaux
droits pour les malades et les soins
palliatifs c'est quelque chose qui n'a
pas pour nous sens et la deuxième chose
qui est à mes yeux aussi
important nous proposons nouveaux droits
pour les personnes il ne faut pas
opposer ces nouveaux
droit au corps
médical c'est quelque chose aussi
d'extrêmement euh important euh nous
pouvons offrir de nouveaux droits aux
patients sans supprimer à l'évidence ce
qui existe naturellement ce dialogue
singulier entre le malade et le médecin
pour nous c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel mais effectivement cette
proposition de loi c'est
constitue de nouveau droit pr donc il y
a ce sujet des directives
anticipées et il y a le deuxième sujet
la
sédation profonde et continue jusqu'au
décès de sujets que Jean va pouvoir vous
présenter dans le détail voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire en renouvelant tous
mes remerciements d'être ici
monsieur le Président messieurs les
rapporteurs madamees messieurs les
sénateurs je joins ma reconnaissance au
propos d'Alain clè pour dire combien
nous sommes reconnaissants effectivement
d'être reçus c'est pas habituel mais
c'est une proposition de loi même si
alinclè a rappelé de dans le cadre dans
lequel cette proposition de loi est
élaborée sur une sur une
mission aide de mission du du Premier
ministre
la deux mesures phar effectivement
existe dans ce texte le premier euh la
première
mesure consiste en
cette action qui
est une sédation profonde et continue
jusqu'au
décès bien entendu le mot sédation n'est
pas
utilisé à l'intérieur du texte puisque
il
s'agit de faire un texte qui explique
simplement que euh dans quelles
conditions on va mettre en place une
diminution de la
vigilance pourquoi serait-elle profonde
pourquoi doit-elle être continue et
pourquoi va-t-elle jusqu'au
décès pour dire les choses assez
simplement
euh nous avons regardé deux situations
la première situation c'est que la
sédation existe aujourd'hui dans notre
pays qu'elle est pratiquée dans des
indications précises en particulier dans
les services de soins
palliatifs mais que en revanche on
constate que de manière
abusive des
patients uniquement parce qu'ils sont en
fin de
vie bénéficie et le terme est mal choisi
de trait associant antalgique et sédatif
même lorsque il n'y a aucune angoisse ou
il n'y a aucune douleur
particulière et là il y a un vrai danger
d'abus d'une thérapeutique qui a une
indication précise et et et en
particulier dans les circonstances dans
lesquelles on a essayé de le définir
dans la
loi la société française de de soins
palliatif définit qu'il y a une
indication dans les lesquel dans
laquelle pour reprendre une expression
qui est un peu simpliste mais qui dit
bien ce qu'elle veut dire on a le droit
de dormir pour ne pas souffrir avant de
mourir dormir bien entendu ça veut dire
que cette sédation est profonde et
qu'elle a pour but à la fois par des
médicaments analgésiques et par des
médicaments
sédatifs d'empêcher toute s ance
physique ou morale
ou tout
inconfort la souffrance n'étant pas
uniquement la douleur physique chacun
sait que mourir en s'étouffant mourir
avec des troubles digestifs majeurs
mourir en vomissant et son sont des
situations d'inconfort qui sont
équivalents à une douleur
physique d'autres patients d'ailleurs se
trouvent dans des situations où l'
angoisse de la proche de la mort peut
entraîner des situations de de grande
panique et comme le dit Régis Sabri
médecin de soins palliatif le malade
n'est pas obligé d'assister au au drame
tragique de sa mort dans ces conditions
quelles sont les deux conditions qui ont
été définies dans la loi pour que l'on
puisse mettre en place cette sédation
profonde autrement dit cette anesthésie
générale pour dire les choses pour
appeler les choses par leur nom médical
la première c'est que la la mort doit
être
imminente je m'expliquerai si vous le
souhaitez pourquoi elle doit être
imminente mais en tout cas nous avons
essayé avec Alain Claise de trouver un
terme qui correspondait bien à
cette proximité de l'échéance
elle est toujours difficile à définir
sur le plan médical mais on sait que
plus on approche de la mort et plus et
moins on se trompe sur la date de la
mort si on dit ce patient va mourir dans
un an on peut se tromper avec des
grosses marges d'erreur si on dit qu'il
va mourir dans les 3 jours qui viennent
on peut se tromper avec des marges
d'erreur relativement plus
limité donc nous avons choisi plutôt que
de mettre phase terminale qui a été un
débat dans le publque sédation en phase
terminale considérons que la phase
terminale est une phase selon euh les
les auditions que nous avons eu qui qui
s'échelonnent pour certains sur une
année ou plusieurs mois en tout cas nous
avons voulu mettre un terme qui
précisait bien que le pronostic vital
était engagé à court
terme ce terme vaut ce qu' vaut mais il
avait au moins l'avantage d'expliquer
que ça n'était pas un décès qui était
prévisible en mois encore moins en année
mais plutôt plôt en heure et en
jour le deuxième élément c'est que la
souffrance ressenti par le malade est
réfractaire c'est le deuxième critère
qu'il y a dans les recommandations de la
société française de soins palliatifs
réfractaire au traitement
habituel ce qui élimine bien entendu je
dirais le la demande de sédation qui
serait
d'origine souffrance
existentielle et qui aurait à ce
moment-là un autre but que d'abriger la
souffrance on n'est plus dans la
souffrance on serait dans la volonté de
mettre fin à sa vie pour
autant soyons clair et qu qu'est-ce qui
se passe dans cette circonstance on est
donc dans une situation dans lequelle
premièrement le malade continue à
souffrir malgré des
traitements
et même si nous avons des évaluations
assez précises d'un certain nombre
d'éléments de souffrance c'est quand
même lui qui est le plus capable de dire
si il est en échappement au traitements
sédatifs et anentalgique ou analgésiqu
qui lui sont proposés
et la mort va survenir dans les heures
ou les jours qui
viennent la limite semaines on se trouve
donc dans une situation dans laquelle on
met en place euh cette
réponse qui est une réponse continue
jusqu'au décès parce que comme la mort
est proche il serait anormal comme cela
peut se faire par ailleurs de réveiller
le malade après une sédation pour
contrôler si l'épisode de souffrance est
résolutif et si l'on peut reprendre une
thérapeutique plus banale que celle qui
existe
précédemment donc nous sommes dans un
dans dans un système dans lequel euh
nous avons pardon de le dire de manière
un peu brutale copier les deux éléments
qui sont les éléments de recommandation
des soins palliatifs la souffrance
réfractaire et la mort
imminente pourquoi la souffrance
réfractaire chacun peut comprendre que
une souffrance légère doit avoir une
réponse adaptée et qu'on ne peut pas
demander de dormir pour ne pas souffrir
avant de mourir alors qu'on peut très
bien euh utiliser des médicaments qui
seraient capable d'obtenir ce
résultat pourquoi
euh continue euh il peut il apparaît aux
malades et au à l'environnement familial
qu'il est euh une souff qu'il est
constitué une que cela constitue une
souffrance supplémentaire que de
réveiller le malade qui a quelques jours
à vivre pour lui demander s'il continue
à souffrir et on imagine bien que les
mêmes causes produiraient les mêmes
effets et que l'arrêt d'un traitement de
ce type entraînerait une récidive et qui
n'aurait pas de sens et donc elle est
continue jusqu'au décès pour éviter ses
allers-retours avec le le le le malade à
nouveau face à à cette souffrance
réfractaire
euh quelle est la différence avec le les
textes précédents parce que c'est
toujours la question qu'on doit se poser
la différ c'est que si on est critique
on peut dire ça
existéit ça a existé ça existait en
service de soins palliatif dans quelques
services
hospitaliers ça existé comme je le
disais de manière plus diffuse sur
l'ensemble des corps médical
hospitaliers sans qu'il y ait des
indications assez précises et puis
surtout ça n'existe pas à domicile ça
n'existe pas enpad comme l'a rappelé
alincl et ça n'existe pas aussi parce
que la culture médicale a du mal à se
faire à ce type de de de situation qui
est assez bien connu par les
anesthésistes réanimateurs bien connu
par les euh médecins de soin piatifs ou
les gérontologues ou les cancérologues
un peu moins par les autres
et on se rend compte que beaucoup de
malades continuent à mal mourir avec des
souffrances dans les dernières heures ou
les derniers jours de leur vie et donc
cet objectif est un objectif de garantie
de non-souffrance dans les derniers
jours les dernières heures de nos vies
le deuxième
point est plus complexe il s'agit des
directives anticipées là aussi les
directives anticipées existent déjà dans
le texte de 2005 le texte disait que
l'on devait en tenir compte forcé de
constater que pour en tenir compte il
faut d'abord qu'elle soit écrite or 2 et
demi % de la population a écrit les
directives
anticipées pour deux raisons majeures la
première c'est que il est extrêmement
difficile lorsqu'on n pas porteur d'une
maladie qu'on ne se sait pas porteur
d'une maladie de rédiger un texte dans
lequel on dit ce qu'on voudrait ou ce
qu'on voudrait pas moi-même chacun le
sait je suis médecin et j'ai essayé de
le faire tardivement il y a 2 ans à
peine ce qui prouve que c'était pas
spontanément facile à faire et je me
suis rapidement heurté à toute une série
de difficultés quand vous commencez à
écrire vous écrivez
si un jour je suis à l' incapacité parce
que j'ai des lésions cérébrales majeures
et irréversibles qui empêch toute
relation à l'autre et toute prise de
conscience de mon existence je
souhaiterais après un délai raisonnable
parce que tu dis bon qui qui me qui se
donne quand même quelques jours pour
réfléchir
euh d'arrêter les traitements de survie
et je me suis m rendu compte qu'il y
avait au moins une demi-douzaine de de
termes médicaux à
l'intérieur donc c'est impossible a
rédigé sur papier libre quelqu'un qui ne
se sait pas porteur d'une maladie c'est
est la situation est différente et nous
avons voulu avec Al inclè garder un seul
texte pour les directiv anticipé alors
qu'en fait il y a deux volets et deux
situations très différentes si par
contre je sais que j'ai une maladie que
je sois médecin ou pas je vais taper sur
un ordinateur je vais savoir comment
peut se terminer cette maladie et ça
peut me faire horreur en tout cas ça
peut me faire peur et donc dans le coloc
singulier souvent les malades demandent
à leur médecins et j'ai lu que ça
pouvait finir comme ça si c'est comme ça
faites en sorte que vous ne fassiez pas
ceci ou ne fassiez pas cela et la
réponse est un dans le collocque
singulier est un est un une réponse de
de confiance et d'engagement solidaire
dans ce contexte on peut donc imaginer
que elles sont plus faciles à rédiger
toujours est-il que le premier point
c'est que pour rédiger des directives
anticipées on s'est un peu inspiré des
modèles allemands suisses ou anglais
dont vous voyez ils ont les législations
sont très différentes mais qui
permettent d'avoir un modèle non pas
quelque chose de simpliste dans lequel
on coche des cases mais un modèle qui
permet une pédagogie et qui permet
d'écrire des choses qui sont
réfléchis pour ma part et c'est à titre
personnel que je le dis je pense qu'il
serait préférable il serait préférable
que ce directive anticipé soit rédigé
avec un dialogue
médical mais j'ai bien compris aussi que
ce dialogue médical pouvait être
intrusif dans l'autonomie de la personne
en tout cas c'est un argument qui nous a
été présenté et qui pouvait pouvait
faire obstacle à à la libre décision des
directives anticipées du citoyen si on
revient sur sur ces directiv anticipées
nous avons proposé que ce soit la Haute
Autorité de santé et le Conseil d'État
pour avoir la sécurité juridique et
médical d'un texte qui avait une
élaboration
euh juridiquement et médicalement
irréprochable ces directives anticipées
sont-elles opposables nous avons préféré
et c'était le terme qu'avait choisi le
Premier ministre dans sa lre de mission
qu'elle soit contraignante
jusqu'à présent les directives
anticipées même si elles sont minimes
sont suivies par les médecins à près de
70 % des cas dans les 30 % des cas il a
été très difficile de savoir si c'est un
refus du corps médical d'appliquer la
volonté du patient ou bien s'il
s'agissait de directive anticipées euh
qui était inadapté à la situation dans
laquelle on se
trouve je cite pardon pour ceux qui
l'ont déjà entendu de situations très
particulières des situations dans
lesquelles euh les directives anticipées
se résument à une terme qui dit je ne
veux pas être hospitalisé on ne doit pas
me toucher à l'hôpital ce qui est une
directive anticipée qui est pas
applicable et d'autres une autre plus
anecdotique mais qui est inscrivé que la
patiente ne voulait aucun
tuyau ce qui rend difficile même la
simple oxygénation dans un transport
médicalisé donc il faut que se poser la
question dans quelles circonstances
directiv anticipé vont-elles s'appliquer
puisque
désormais le texte dit qu'il y a un
modèle le texte dit que ça n'est pas les
souhaits du malade mais la volonté du
malade et que ces directives anticipées
elle concernent bien entendu vous le
savez les conditions de refus ou de
limitation ou d'arrêt des traitements
médicaux directives anticipé ne peuvent
pas demander une injection mortelle par
exemple dans le cadre du de la loi
actuelle donc elle s'impose au médecin
dit
alors si elles s'imposent au médecin
elles sont
opposables sauf que il y a deux
situations dans lequell elles ne sont
pas opposables la première c'est
l'urgence vitale et l'urgence vitale a
deux raisons une raison je dirais de de
mise en œuvre des procédures de
réanimation qui
sont pardon vis-à-vis des réanimateurs
mais comme je le suis aussi je peux
faire la critique qui sont relativement
stéréotypés le massage cardiaque
l'intupation la mise en place des voies
centrales tout ça nécessite des gestes
techniques qui doivent être mis en place
assez rapidement et on voit mal même si
les directives anticipées sont
facilement accessibles par la carte
vitale ou plutôt comme l'a proposé
madame la ministre par un registre ça
n'est pas dans ces conditions on n'est
pas dans les conditions dans lesquelles
on peut de manière
sereine regarder les directives
anticipées et les appliquer ou ne pas
les appliquer j'ajoute que que le fait
de mettre les urgences vitales élimine
le problème du suicide qui est quand
même un problème majeur or nous savons
tous que continuerons dans les hôpitaux
à et dans les les services à réanimer
les malades qui attendent à leur jour et
et avec un argument qui est assez clair
quand même c'est qu'il y a quand même 60
à 70 % des personnes qui attendent
réellement à leur jour euh et qui ne
récidivent jamais ce qui veut bien dire
que la volonté et l'autonomie est un
élément fluctuant et que la liberté
c'est justement de pouvoir changer
d'avis en démocratie comme en médecine
pour soi-même donc dans ces conditions
elle s'impose au médecin sauf en cas
d'urgence vitale et nous avons ajouté
pendant le temps nécessaire pour
vérifier que parce que là il y a un
piège législatif textuel c'est que si on
dit que toutes les urgences V
sont
opposables à une directive anticipée ça
veut dire qu'il n'y a plus de directive
anticipé puisque à la fin la vie se
termine et que si chaque fois que la vie
se termine alors que les directives
anticiper dit par par exemple si je me
trouve dans telle ou telle condition je
veux pas je veux qu'on arrête les
traitements vitaux de survie et que on
dit oui mais puisque c'est des
traitements vitaux on les poursuit
malgré les directiv anticipé on tue
complètement la possibilité des
directives anticipées donc cette urgence
vitale elle permet simplement de faire
le point de réanimer de faire les gestes
nécessaires le temps de pouvoir
effectivement de manière
sereine regarder le caractère approprié
ou non à la situation des directives
anticipées ensuite on a mis un un un un
une autre
formule qui est qui est discutable mais
qui est manifestement inapproprié
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une directive
anticipé manifestement
inapproprié plutôt que de trouver une
formule différente on a essayé d'avoir
une formule large parce qu'elle
correspond d'une part à des directives
anticipées pardon du terme farfelu tel
que je les ai évoqué tout à l'heure mais
elle correspond aussi à des situations
dans lesquelles la réversibilité de la
situation médicale que l'on voit
euh est
évidente un malade qui ferait pardon
d'utiliser les termes médicaux mais une
hypoglycémie une chute du sucre dans le
sang et qui serait dans le comun il
suffirait de lui donner une injection de
de sucre et et et il reviendrait à
l'état antérieur donc on ne pourrait pas
opposer une directive anticipée sur une
situation qui permet un restitutium
intégro de intégrome de de la situation
antérieure euh vous connaissez tous
cette cette anecdote cette personne qui
a un seul poumon qui est qui veut pas
être réanimé finalement qui est réanimé
parce c'est un épisode grippal et que
l'épisode grippal lorsqu'il est terminé
ne ne met pas en jeu le pronostic n'est
pas une évolution particulière de la
maladie et puis il y a il y a un troème
élément c'est le caractère inadapté à la
pathologie je c'est porteur d'une
pathologie je ne veux pas que dans
l'évolution de cette pathologie euh on
on on poursuive de manière
déraisonnable les traitements quand et
si je suis inconscient je l'écris enfin
plutôt je l'écris dans le cas où je
serai inconscient
mais si j'ai
euh une maladie vasculaire cérébrale et
que j'ai peur d'avoir des lésions qui
qui euh empêche mon cerveau de
fonctionner de manière normale et que je
marque dans les directives anticipées si
j'ai une récidive de mon hémorragie
cérébrale je ne veux pas que et cetera
si par contre je suis renversé par une
voiture et que je suis inconscient je
suis pas dans le cadre de la maladie et
donc là aussi je suis dans une situation
qui est inappropriée manifestement
inappropriée donc compenu du caractère
multifactoriel et de la diversité des
situations inappropriées nous avons
préféré ne pas les les les
lister vous savez avec la sagesse du
Sénat que plus on on met de détails et
plus on en oublie et et plus on crée un
certain nombre de problèmes et donc nous
avons simplement défini une procédure
qui oblige le médecin à ce moment-là à
consulter un autre collègue et à
inscrire les raisons de la non
application ou de ou du non suivi des
directives anticipées sur le dossier
médical après avoir recueil cet avis
voilà pour les directives
anticipées sur la personne de confiance
nous avons après discussion préféré
laisser là aussi un éventail large ça
peut être un parent un proche un médecin
traitant je dirais ça peut être tout le
monde mais c'est plutôt bien que ça
puisse être tout le monde plutôt que il
y a eu un débat savoir s'il fallait
éliminer un médecin traitant de de la
personne de confiance
nous avons pensé qui que c'était une
possibilité ni pas une obligation mais
une possibilité on a aussi arguer que
les proches ne devaient pas être trop
proches parce que l'affectif est
toujours difficile mais comment comment
éviter que la confiance se fasse
vis-à-vis des personnes qui soient les
plus proches de nous donc la personne de
confiance on peut pas dire ça n'est
sûrement pas la famille et ça n'est
sûrement pas un médecin le médecin
traitant la personne de conf ance elle
est choisie dans
un climat de confiance
entre le patient et et et la personne
qui
accepte le dernier
point parce que je tousse tout le temps
ans pas la
d'accord permettez-moi de dire que c'est
à la fois inquiétant que ça dure mais
rassurant que ce soit sur une période
aussi
longue donc qu'est-ce que la personne de
confiance dit jusqu'à présent le texte
antérieur disait qu'on recueillait la
vie de la famille ou des proches et que
la personne de confiance avait un avis
qui prévalait sur tout autre avis non
médical son avis continue à prévaloir
mais sur l'ensemble du texte au lieu de
recueillir la vie on recueille le
témoignage
pourquoi l'affaire Vincent Lambert nous
a appris que nous a rappelé que les
familles sont diverses dans leurs
opinions leurs convictions y compris
leurs convictions religieuses et
qu'elles peuvent donc émettre émettre
des avis différents l'avantage de la
personne de confiance c'est qu'on a un
interlocuteur privilégié qui ayant eu la
confiance du patient lorsqu'il était en
capacité d'exprimer sa volonté et et
quand même le le plus fidèle de ce qu'
révolue le patient
néanmoins lorsque la personne de
confiance n'est pas désignée ce qui est
malheureusement et qui continuera à être
même dans les pays qui ont développé
tout cela on arrive à 15 % on arrive pas
à 100 % de personnes et je pense à titre
personnel que c'est pas une bonne idée
ça a été évoqué aussi que ce soit
obligatoire on n'est pas obligé
d'envisager sa mort voilà on peut peut
on peut être plutôt du côté de Spinoza
qui dit réfléchissons sur la vie que du
côté de Montaigne qui dit réfléchissons
sur notre mort voilà donc si on est
plutôt spinoiste on va continuer à dire
qu'on n pas obligé de faire des
directives anticipées si on n'est pas
obligé de temps en temps il y en aura
pas quand il y en a pas on on se tourne
vers la famille et les proches est-ce
que la famille est supérieure aux
proches et c'est un débat qui a eu et
est-ce qu'à l'intérieur de la famille il
y a une hiérarchie je crois qu'il y a un
vrai danger à mettre une hiérarchie à
l'intérieur d'une famille et un vrai
aussi a considéré que le proche euh ne
serait pas plus proche dans certaines
circonstances que la famille la personne
qui vit avec quelqu'un pendant 10 ans et
quand même plus proche d'elle même s'il
y a pas de liens familiaux que la
famille éloigné et et qui c'est tout
juste que la personne continue à exister
donc on a préféré ne pas mettre de
hiérarchie mais en en revanche on est
passé sur le témoignage chacun connaît
euh la situation qui est en train de
bouger
d'ailleurs sur la le don d'organe on
demande pas aux gens ce qu'ils veulent
on leur demande qu'est-ce que la
personne à votre avis aurait voulu et
c'est un peu ça que nous avons essayé
avec Alain cl d'introduire dans ce texte
c'est que la vie de cette personne qui
peut plus s'exprimer était il avait une
personnalité il avait des convictions
philosophiques il avait des convictions
religieuses il s'était
devant des proches devant la famille
devant une personne et que ce témoignage
là vaut bien sûr il vaut moins que
l'expression directe de la volonté
puisque c'est une volonté par
anticipation et par personne interposée
mais ça vaut mieux que rien ça vaut
mieux que de ne pas savoir qui était
cette personne et qu'est-ce qu'elle
aurait éventuellement voulu donc cette
modification là est une modification qui
est peut-être un peu passé inaperçu mais
qui est significative on ne recueille
plus la vie mais le témoignage
enfin l'autorité parentale
et le juge des tutelles en cas de
tutelle prime sur la personne de
confiance parce que la personne de
confiance a pas autant de pouvoir que
quelqu'un qui qui qui a qui est tuteur
ou ou qui a l'autorité parentale sur un
enfant donc un enfant ne peut pas
désigner de personnes de confiance
d'abord parce qu'il est pas adul et en
capacité de le faire et ensuite parce
que du fait de la loi l'autorité
parentale et nous avons voulu le
rappeler et le préciser je voudrais
rentrer dans un dernier ou deux ou trois
derniers détails qui est qui sont ce
euh la nutrition et l'hydratation
artificielle constitue un
traitement
euh al cl et moi-même pensons
aujourd'hui qu'on aurait pu ne pas le
mettre dans le texte non pas parce que
ça n'est pas une vérité mais parce que
c'est c'est devenu une
évidence c'est une évidence puisque si
on regarde les le texte de 2005 si on
dit bien que on peut arrêter tout
traitement c'est bien à la suite d'un
débat qui consiste à dire pas le
traitement mais tout traitement
signifiant bien que un traitement c'est
au fond toute intrusion sur le corps de
l'autre et qui nécessite l'acceptation
de l'autre le soin je te donne à manger
le le le je je mets un tube dans
l'estomac l'attracher les
veines à l'intérieur du corps forcément
c'est une thérapeutique comment peut-on
envisager d'ailleurs que que le fait de
mettre un tuyau dans l'estomac par voie
chirurgicale pour apporter des
nutriments puissent être considéré comme
un soin c'est évidemment un traitement
il y il y a sur ce sujet une symbolique
forte qui fait que personne ne dit
lorsqu'on arrête un respirateur que le
malade meurt étouffé mais continue à
penser que lorsqu'on arrête
l'hydratation et la nutrition
artificielle le malade meurt de faim et
de soif c'est une c'est un nonsens
médical et c'est ça n'est pas une
réalité surtout si la sédation profonde
et continue à mise en place personne en
se réveillant d'une anesthésie a dit
j'ai eu faim à soif voilà personne
d'ailleurs ne dit j'ai eu mal donc c'est
bien on a au moins cette expérience là
donc dans ce contexte oui on l'a rappelé
je rappelle que le Conseil d'État dans
l'affaire Vincent Lambert a rappelé
qu'effectivement le
traitement l'hydratation et la nutrition
artificielle était un
traitement bon ça a pu apparaître comme
un élément nouveau alors que c'est un
élément ancien et comme un élément
novateur alors que c'est
un pour les médecins c'est une évidence
on ne peut pas mettre un tube dans
l'estomac de quelqu'un sans lui demander
son avis c'est bien la preuve qu'on est
dans une situation dans laquelle on met
en place une thérapeutique qu'il doit
accepter voilà ce que je voudrais
simplement rappeler aussi que le double
effet était mal
écrit dans la loi 2005 il était mal
écrit puisqu'il était écrit dans un dans
une phrase de détournement si j'ose dire
puisqu'on disait lorsqu'il y a un double
effet pour dire les choses
sans revenir au texte lorsqu'il y a un
double effet il faut il faut l'écrire
sur le sur le dossier médical évitant
d'expliquer ce que c'était qu'un double
effet ce qui était d'une façon un peu un
peu curieuse le double effet ça ne peut
pas
être un argumentaire de double
intentionnalité pour autant on ne peut
pas envisager de ne pas mettre des
traitements qui soulage la
souffrance en raison de la possibilité
qu'elles auraient d'avirgé la
vie sinon nous aurons beaucoup de
malades qui continueront à souffrir
parce queon regardera la la dose toxique
dans le Vidal et on dira on le fait pas
parce que c'est dangereux pour pour la
survie nous avons donc choisi un terme
qui vaut ce qui vaut là aussi et qui est
le même si même si c'est-à-dire que pour
répondre à à la souffrance on met en
place un traitement analgique et sédatif
même si ils peuvent avoir comme effet
d'abriger la vie le même si veut bien
dire la même chose on a débattu avec
Alain cl et c'est à son initiative et il
a raison de ne pas mettre le mot
secondaire parce que chacun sait ce que
c'est que le double effet chacun sait
que c'est une c'est une invention Thomas
Saint- Thomas Daquin et qui dit que une
action bonne peut avoir une action
secondaire mauvaise ici l'action bonne
c'est de soulager la souffrance l'action
secondaire mauvaise c'est d'abréger la
vie et donc c'est un peu curieux de dire
le mot secondaire en français veut dire
deux choses consécutif
ou négligeablees et c'est difficile de
dire que l'effet secondaire d'un d'un
d'un traitement et et et de raccourcir
la vie et donc il vaut mieux utiliser la
on a pensé qu'il valait mieux utiliser
la formule même si plutôt que de dire
même si cela peut avoir comme effet
secondaire d'abrger la vie le le le
rapprochement des deux termes avec
quelque chose qui nous paraissait un
peu difficile
donc voilà l'ensemble des des des
dispositifs je rappelle que la sédation
je n'ai envisagé que le premier alinéa
de de la mise en place de la sédation à
la demande du malade il y en a deux
autres il y en a un qui est aujourd'hui
inscrit dans le 373 du compte de
déontologie et qui dit en gros que
lorsqueun malade a des lésion cérébrale
majeure et qui lui empêche d'exprimer sa
volonté et que sa souffrance est
impossible à évaluer du fait de son
absence
d'expression le médecin met en œuvre
dans le 373 il y a écrit met en œuvre en
œuvre c'est-à-dire c'est à l'indicatif
c'est pas peut mettre en œuvre c'est
mettre en œuvre donc c'est ça vaut un
impératif met en œuvre un traitement
antalgique et sédatif pour éviter toute
souffrance
potentielle je reviens pas sur la fière
Pierra que vous connaissez probablement
qui qui est ce ce jeune homme à qui on
arrête tous les traitements mais on ne
poursuit pas les soins et qui meurt dans
un tableau d'agonie et de souffrance
vis-à-vis de sa famille assez important
donc et effectivement dans ce cas-là on
a insisté sur des choses qui nous
paraissaient évidentes c'est que
lorsqu'on arrête un traitement on met en
place un un traitement qui empêche que
l'arrêt du traitement de survie ne soit
vécu avec une souffrance potentielle et
qu'en même temps que la famille et est
droit pardon du terme à le au spectacle
d'une vie finissante de manière sereine
et apaisé c'est la raison pour laquelle
le 373 est arrivé en 2008 à la suite de
la
révision de la loi de 2005 et que ce
texte a été mis en place plutôt que de
le laisser dans le code de déontologie
on l'a monté donc dans le texte et donc
désormais l'arrêt d'un traitement de
survie qu'il soit à la demande du malade
ou qu'il
soit la réflexion collégiale qui
constate une obstination
déraisonnable l'arrêt de ces traitements
de survie est obligatoirement assorti
mais comment ferait-on autrement d'une
sédation profonde et contenue jusqu'au
décès on est dans un contexte très
particulier là le décès va arriver à
court terme et pourquoi il va arriver à
court terme parce que c'est un
traitement de survie qui est interrompu
et donc il est évident que on va pas
courir le risque d'une souffrance
potentielle qui serait aggravé par un
traitement de survie qui serait arrêté
donc dans ces deux cas-là c'est les deux
autres cas envisagés la sédation
profonde et continue jusqu'au décès est
mise en place pardon d'avoir été un un
petit peu long mais je je je voulais
dire pourquoi nous avions eu des
hésitations et des difficulté je viens
sur deux
points qui restent pour nous deux et et
pour les les députés un sujet euh euh
d'insatisfaction le texte dit à la
demande du patient d'éviter toute
souffrance et de ne pas a prolongé
inutilement sa
vie le mot inutilement a été sujet à
polémique donc comme c'est moi qu'il
introduit j'enorte la responsabilité et
la culpabilité ce que nous voulions dire
au fond c'est que il y avait ce lâcher
prise qui consistait à dire non
seulement à la fois je sais que ma mort
est proche puisque c'est le malade qui
qui parle et qui est qui demande je sais
que ma mort est proche et je continue à
souffrir donc je veux pas être prolongé
et et en même temps je veux pas souffrir
et c'est pour ça que la sédation
profonde et continue jusqu'au décès
intervient pour autant le terme inutile
a été interprété comme des vies sont
inutiles aucune vie n'est inutile mais
des prolongations peuvent être inutiles
je rappelle que dans le code
d'udéontologie il y a écrit que le
médecin ne doit pas prolonger
inutilement l'agonie alors dans ce
contexte le mot inutile était acceptable
ici il paraît moins AC acceptable lors
du débat euh plusieurs propositions ont
été faites doit pas être prolongé par
une obstination déraisonnable pour
reprendre les termes antérieurs ne doit
pas être pronongé abusivement enfin
voilà il y a il y a là un sujet je
reconnais moi ça me choque pas de ne pas
prolonger inutilement la vie parce que
c'est la prolongation qui peut paraître
inutile et c'est le malade qui peut dire
effectivement que cette prolongation est
inutile mais pour autant le le l'élément
là est un élément peut-être que cet
adverbe peut-être utilement
changé enfin le l'autre interrogation
c'est arrête un traitement de maintien
en vie et bien entendu vous avez compris
que l'arrêt d'un traitement de maintien
en vie on peut choisir l'arrêt d'un
traitement de survie l'arrê ce que l'on
voulait dire c'est que le la vie du
malade dépend de la poursite suite de ce
traitement donc là aussi il y a eu un un
débat sur la terminologie qui avait été
utilisé et et et qui pose un problème
enfin la procédure collégiale est restée
dans les mêmes
dispositifs que qu'antérieurement je
rappelle que la procédure collégiale
dans le cadre d'un droit nouveau qui la
demande du malade opposable d'avoir une
sédation à condition que deux conditions
soient requises la mort imminente et la
souffrance réfractaire la collégialité
n'a pas pour objet et là aussi c'est un
sujet de tension mais vous verrez qu'il
a c'est un sujet
aussi majeur la collégialité n'a pas
pour objet de décider de l'opportunité
ou pas de faire de répondre à ce droit
mais de vérifier que les deux conditions
sont requises autrement dit le médecin
la collégialité médicale ne peut pas
dire la sédation profond continue
jusqu'au décès euh vous avez une
souffrance réfractaire et la mort est
imminente mais nous estimons que on ne
doit pas y faire droit si les deux
conditions vérifi médicalement que la
mort est imminente et que la la
souffrance et réfractaire le malade a
droit et donc la collégialité médicale
je le dis ça énerve un peu les médecins
de temps en temps mais la collégialité
médicale n'est pas là en opportunité
elle est là en vérification que les deux
conditions qui sont des conditions
d'appréciation médicale sont requises
pardon d'avoir été l' monsieur le
Président et Alain class et moi-même
bien sûr sont à disposition pour
répondre à vos questions c'était pas
long c'était intéressant merci je passer
la parole à nos rapporteurs à nous
Gérard deot et Michel Amiel on commence
par Gérard oui je vais commencer tout
d'abord pour vous remercier messieurs
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et je
pense que c'était tout à fait utile et
même indispensable parce que ça a permis
à à travers toutes les les commentaires
que vous avez pu faire sur le texte que
vous avez produit ça a permis déjà de
d'éliminer j'allais dire un certain
nombre de questions qui étaient de toute
façon sous-jacentes et qu'on aurait posé
mais qu'on posera peut-être quand même
d'ailleurs et comme on s'est partager un
peu les les choses euh j'ai laissé à
Michel la partie sédation moi reprenant
plus les les parties enfin en gros hein
les parties euh euh directive anticipé
disons et euh justement vous terminiez
tout à l'heure par le problème de la
décision collégiale il y a une question
qui se pose en permanence pour quelqu'un
qui voit ça comme ça en disant mais
finalement il y a bien quand même
quelqu'un qui décide à la fin et donc ce
quelqu'un c'est qui puisceque la
décision collégiale elle peut être dans
la discussion collégiale c'est évident
mais à la fin il faut bien qu'il y ait
une personne qui décide et puis moi je
voudrais rajouter une chose c'est que je
voudrais le dire d'abord déjà dans le
texte de 2005 je pense que c'était un
texte équilibré alors certes qu' avait
sans doute des lacunes des défauts et
c'est pour ça aussi qu'il a était
nécessaire de corriger ce que vous avez
fait dans un certain nombre de domaines
mais qui ont permis malgré qui a permis
ce texte à mon avis de prendre en compte
disons la quasi-ttalité des situations
dans lesquelles peuvent se trouver et le
corps médical et le les patient et je
crois qu'à travers cette PPL que vous
avez commise et bien il y a déjà la
réponse à un C certain nombre de lacunes
qui pouvaient exister ou tout au moins
de précision et tout à l'heure quand
vous parliez justement de nutrition et
alimentation artificielle étant un
traitement je pense qu'il était
nécessaire malgré tout personnellement
je pense qu'il était nécessaire que ce
soit marqué dans le texte parce que
c'était tellement une question qui était
en permanence reposée par tel ou tel ce
qui peut se comprendre d'ailleurs mais à
partir du moment où c'est précisé dans
le texte au moins je pense que ce genre
de questions n'apparaîtront plus et puis
puis donc cette décision collégiale la
nécessité de mettre pour moi nutrition
et alimentation artificielle dans le
texte ça me semble important
et par ailleurs une question simplement
globale pourquoi le texte de 2005 a été
aussi peu connu et aussi peu appliqué il
l'était puisque finalement il reprenait
les ce qui se pratiquait déjà bien sûr
mais pourquoi il y a-t-il eu aussi peu
de de de de de de je de publicité parce
que j'ai pas d'autres termes autour de
ça mais c'est pas le terme mais tout au
moins de de vulgarisation pour que
l'ensemble des services médicaux
l'applique avec avec le l'application
réellement d'une loi qui existait
maintenant puisqu'elle avait été voté et
je pense que là il y aura aussi ce que
j'espère bien sûr c'est que ce soit voté
la PPL mais que là aussi il y ait
justement une vulgarisation beaucoup
plus grande et qui permette justement de
mieux connaître et que tout le monde
connaisse que tout le monde sache et que
ce soit appliqué alors voilà moi
j'aurais pas d'autres questions que
celle les deux petites questions que je
vais vous poser pu je laisserai la
parole à Michel pour parler plus de la
partie sédation et enfin si j'oublier là
encore vous l'avez dit l'un et l'autre
euh ENF je pourquoi justement il y
a-t-il aussi peu de service de soins
palliatif qui a été mis en place depuis
le temps que l'on sait les uns et les
autres que c'est une des solutions
indispensables dans la période de fin de
vie et donc si vous pouviez nous
apporter quelques informations même si
on a une petite idée mais réellement
pour voir pour
compléter merci Michel
oui merci aussi d'avoir apporté de
nombreux éclaircissements à des
questions qui ont déjà été posées dans
le cadre de des auditions que nous avons
entreprises
alors pour rentrer dans le le le les
trois points qui me paraissent
effectivement difficiles de l'article 3
concernant la sédation profonde
effectivement on a buté sur prolonger
inutilement sa vie la notion d'inutilité
n'est pas dans le prolongement mais dans
la vie et effectivement une lecture je
dis pas rapide mais de de de ce texte
bute là-dessus peut-être revenir
effectivement un terme d'obstination des
raisonnbles pour ne pas choquer les
esprits en TER d'utilité enfin c'est une
hypothèse mais c'est revenu souvent dans
les auditions que nous avons déjà eu y
compris dans les débats que nous avons
pu avoir informellement en
interne le deuxième point toujours de
cet article lorsque la décision du
patient atteind une affection grave et
incurable d'arrêter un
traitement est-ce qu'il ne faudrait pas
préciser quel type de traitement style
traitement de survie alors on va prendre
l'exemple typique un patient diabétique
qui décide d'arrêter l'insuline engage
son pronostic vital à court terme
ah il sera dans un enfin pardon pour un
N médecin il sera dans un coma
acidocétosique dans un délai de moins
d'une semaine est-ce que ce type de
patient a droit à une sédation profonde
bien sûr que
non ce type d'arrêt de traitement
relèverait plutôt d'une forme de suicide
mais si on met ça dans un contexte de
gravité tel que la loi l'aborde je donc
forcer un peu le trait le même patient
diabétique insulinodépendant bien
entendu qui a perdu la vue qui est en
insuffisance rénale et qui a été amputé
d'un membre on est dans une situation
très grave de vie donc peut-être
peut-être arrêter un traitement de
survie et non pas de maintien en vie
puisque dans le cas que j'ai cité
l'insuline maintient en vie de survie
serait peut-être pas mal enfin c'est une
suggestion et le trème point toujours de
cet article 3 dans l'alinéa 7 c'est un
point de détail je pense qu'il y a
quelque chose qui a été oublié tout
simplement mais qu'il faut mettre
tellement la fin de vie en N pas des
dramatiques comme vous l'avez dit le
vendredi soir il y a plus personne et
combien de personnes âgées se sont
retrouvées dans une situation
d'hospitalisation inutile tiens là oui
j'emploie le mot inutile se retrouvant
au urgen et décédant aux urgences quand
ce n'est pas en réanimation donc tout ça
pour dire que c'est après consultation
du médecin en établissement de santé ou
à au domicile du patient ou alors on va
dire dans un établissement médico-social
peut-être puisque c'est le troisème cas
de figure en épad euh établissement un
épad nétant pas un établissement de de
santé voilà les trois points concernant
l'article 3 dont je me suis peut-être un
peu plus spécialement occupé
euh une question d'ordre beaucoup plus
général est-ce qu'on peut considérer que
cette loi est un rééquilibrage entre le
droit du patient et le pouvoir du
mèdecin je dis bien le pouvoir du
médecin pas le savoir du médecin et puis
peut-être un petit regret même si vous
l'avez évoqué par
rapport à la responsabilité l'autorité
parentale ou la mise sous tutelle le
implique le le le le cas dramatique de
la mort des enfants y compris en
néonatologie mais on a le sentiment tant
bien évid évidemment le le sujet est à
ce point inommable au sens étymologique
du mot que le sujet a été
éludé même si juridiquement il ne l'est
pas est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas tout de
même l'évoquer en rappelant bien entendu
que ces cas relèvent de l'autorité
parentale et de la tutelle y compris
hier dans une audition en
particulier on avait le sentiment que on
évoquait finalement la mort que dans le
cadre de de du cancer en phase terminale
ou des personnes
malheureusement la mor c'est aussi celle
des enfants voire des tout petits dans
le cadre de la
néonate merci messieurs les auteurs
c'est à
vous quelques
pointsend partir à Tage
d'ordard pourquoi le texte 2005 a été
insuffisamment
connu on on s'est
interrogé
moi je vous répondre c'est la prière
fois je vais le dire dans ces term là
mais je le fais
ici parce que les fondations de cette
loi n'existaient pas je ve dire par là
que l'absence de développement de soins
palliatifs l'absence de structure
permettant cela a
fait que cette loi n'a pas pu se
développer comme elle aurait dû se
développer
je crois que c'était significatif tout à
l'heure ce que disait
Jean des choses qui sont contenues dans
cette proposition de loi existait
potentiellement dans la loi de
2005 et je pense que s'il y a pas des
mesures
urgentes qui seront qui doivent être
prises que ce soit sur la formation des
médecins et le président de la
République a pris des engagements
lorsque nous avons remis le rapport et
sur les soins palliatifs et ça fait
l'objet de développement et on a
interpellé le Gouvernement sur ce sujet
nous serons confrontés au même au mêmes
difficultés je crois qu'il y a
véritablement aujourd'hui une prise de
conscience en France une priorité
sur ce sujetl je reviendrai pas sur la
nutrition et l'ation
artificielle vous dites vous-même que ça
doit figurer dans le texte Jean a été
très explicite tout à l'heure c'est ce
que nous avons
fait sur la décision collégial
euh rendra peut-être sûrement à la fin
qui décide de
médecin euh on
pourra sur Michel Amiel sur le
prolongement
inutile prolonger inutilement sa vie on
a eu ce débat on a souhaité euh
maintenir ce terme
sachant qu'il pouvait interprété
différemment je n'ai rien à rajouter à
ce qu'a dit Jean tout à l'heure il l'a
replacé dans le contexte tel qu'on le
souhaitait dire c'est un sujet de de
débat
légitime droit de patient pouvoir du
médecin cette proposition de ne prend
pas le contrepied de la loi 2005 prend
pas le contrepied mais c'est
vrai
que cette loi est présentée comme telle
à travers de nouveaux
droits du patient mais c'estes nouveaux
droits du patient ne sont
pas en contradiction avec les
prérogatives du prérogatives du médecin
et je pense que le débat qui a été
ouvert et je disais en apparé au
président tout à l'heure sur les
directives anticipées c'est sur ce
sujetl peut-être hein sur ces directives
anticipé que nouveaux droits patient
d'un côté prérogatif du médecin va se
poser et contrairement à ce qu'on
pouvait imaginer c'est peut-être sur ce
sujet-l où il y a le le plus à à
débattre à débattre entre nous voilà ce
que je veux
dire les textes j'espère que ce texte ne
sera pas ne subira pas
cette cette situation mais les textes
parlementaires ont moins de force que
les textes
gouvernementaux peut-être parce que les
moyens de diffusion de l'information qui
suivent sont moins importants que euh
que dans un cas que que dans l'autre
peut-être aussi parce que les lois qui
sont votées à l'unanimité nous
paraissent banales l qu'elles sont pas
le fruit d'un affrontement sanglant
entre l'opposition et la majorité elles
apparaissent pas comme des modifications
significative je crois qu'Al a raison
c'était une modification culturelle
profonde sans base solide pour les
appliquer ensuite je pense à titre
personnel que le débat en France en tout
cas dans les
médias c'est toujours limité à à une
situation qui est qui est pas
négligeable et qui est pas médiocre qui
est le fait de savoir est-ce qu'il y a
un droit à la mort dans certaines
circonstances et que ce débat a
occulté tout le reste et qu'on a oublié
les 30 % de Français qui meurent mal en
se posant la question de de savoir si on
devait ouvrir un droit à à
mourir dans dans des conditions de
suicide assisté auouthonasie et je pense
que on a tellement focalisé le le débat
que que sur ce sujet qu'on en a oublié
la condition générale dans lesqueles
l'insatisfaction existe et combien cette
insatisfaction alimente la demande de
mort sur
euh l'élément Alain Cless a rappelé que
nous avons dit au président de la
République qui a pris cet engagement
public que si les lois toute la vie
n'est pas dans le droit tout le droit
n'est pas dans la loi et que si il n'y a
pas une formation de l'ensemble des
médecins et des soignants s'il y a pas
une culture palliative qui se met en
place s'il n'y a pas une appropriation
par l'ensemble de nos concitoyens du
problème de la mort qui n'est pas un
problème uniquement médical bien nous
aurons dans les années qui vont
venir un débat insatisfaisant parce que
nous nous verrons que la loi dans 10 ans
elle sera encore mal connu et mal
appliqué sur la
néonath c'est le cas le plus difficile à
gérer quelle vie mérite d'être vécu et
qui en
décide dans le contexte dans lequel on
se trouve Balé le colloc singulier
balayer les directives anticipées
impossible d'aller demander un avis à
une mère pour savoir si on poursuit ou
si on poursuit pas on est dans dans la
dans dans
l'impasse éthique qui fait que
effectivement c'est une c'est une
collégialité médicale qui doit prendre
la responsabilité sur des normes et des
valeurs qui sont affirmées sur le plan
national et universel que que que les
décisions sont prise
euh le texte dit cependant le texte dit
cependant
que s'agissant des mineurs les
titulaires de l'autorité parentale sont
réputés être personnes de confiance on a
voulu le rappeler pour que il y ait pas
d'ambiguïé sur cette situation mais je
pense que la néonatologie est le
problème le plus le plus difficile à à
gérer c'est c'est presque je vais dire
chose qui est faux mais c'est presque la
mort avant la vie donc ou la non vie et
donc queles que soient les croyances que
l'on peut avoir c'est c'est un c'est un
sujet de de de tension éthique très fort
sur les je suis d'accord sur l'idée que
c'est le je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
monsieur le rapporteur traitement de
surve est bien mieux que le TR
traitement de maintien en vie on a voulu
faire mieux et finalement on fait moins
bien mais cependant je rappelle que
c'est arrêter un traitement qui engage
le pronostic vital à court
terme c'est pas
euh c'est un c'est c'est plus le
respirateur qu'on arrête chez le patient
qui a une sclérose latérale rophique et
qui demande d'arrêter le traitement de
survie que celui qui arrête son
traitement
euh diabétique parce que le plus il faut
que le court terme existe on peut peut
pas dire j'arrête mes médicaments euh si
j'arrête mes mes mes mes médicaments à
moyen terme je vais mourir et donc je
demande une sédation profonde et
continue je ne peux demander une séation
profonde et continue si on est toujours
dans le court terme la mort va survenir
à court terme donc à court terme
j'accepte que ce soit continu et
j'accepte que ce soit une censation
profonde je pense que là-dessus
effectivement il y a il y a une une
amélioration à faire la décision elle
est est-elle la décision est-elle
collégiale en droit pénal la
collégialité pénale existe pas voilà
donc la décision elle est prise par un
médecin et peut-être qu'il vaudrait
mieux essayer de dire que les procédures
sont collégiales et que la décision à la
fin elle est prise par celui qui est en
responsabilité et en charge de de la
situation
euh répondu à vos questions j'en ai
oublié une oui
nonattends que j'en c'est bon c'est bon
je
je je relis pas mes
notes pi donc nous allons passer aux
questions de notre CE collègue je
voudrais juste vous demander avant Alain
Cless et et Michel Amiel ont fait
souvent allusion aux personnes âgées qui
qui partaient de l'épade pour aller
mourir à l'hôpital il y a une loi de
santé qui qui est passée chez vous qui
va être votée ou qui a été voté hier
après-midi euh dans laquelle on parle
des ght est-ce que il a été prévu dans
le cas de ces ght que les établissements
en particulier pad fassent partie des
ght de de l'IRE d'influence des hôpitaux
si c'est pas cas on va le faire au
niveau du
Sénat oui pourquoi pas groupement
hospitalier territoire
hpitali c'est
important sur un
amendement je peux balayer les
amendements rapidement qui ont été
adopté qui ont modifié le T oui
oui Changer le
mot analgésie par analgésique
bon le mot inutilement a été débattu et
en sur la sagesse du Sénat pour trouver
une formule plus adéquate la personne de
confiance amendem la personne de
confiance peut avoir accès au dossier
médical contre la vie des rapporteurs et
contre la vie du gouvernement
adopté création d'un registre national
et directiv anticipé nous avions proposé
que ce soit sur la carte Vitale la
ministre a dit que ça serait ass ses
yeux plus efficac que soit sur un
registre voilà accepter amandement accep
euh la sédation possible à domicile
voilà donc la sédation possible à
domicile ça va entraîner toute une série
de décrets qui va faire que des
médicaments comm lipnovel vont être
prescrits en dehors de la MM initiale et
que dans les épades qui sont en fait un
domicile on doit on doit pouvoir aussi
bénéficier parce que le le ce qui serait
terrible ce serait qu'il y ait une une
territorialité des droits pourrait avoir
ces nouveaux droits que dans un service
hospitalier ça serait un peu un petit
peu curieux ensuite le gouvernement
remet chaque année un rapport sur les
soins palliatifs avec l'angoisse enfin
l'inquiétude pardon de de de dire bah
les soins palliatifs si ça se développe
pas si la culture change pas si la
formation change pas on se retrouvera au
même situation qu'aujourd'hui la loi
s'applique bien sûr en
Nouvelle-Calédonie et les ARS présentent
un un un rapport annuel de la situation
du développement des des de
l'organisation des sontif voilà les
principales euh mais il y a bien que
désormais la cédation enfin les le le le
droit nouveau s'applique aussi au
domicile merci Monsieur mouiller à levé
le premier la main oui merci merci pour
votre présentation alors c'est plutôt
des des interrogations ou des
inquiétudes d' d'un néophite je ne suis
pas médecin et donc je n'ai pas
forcément toute la culture mais en tous
les cas j'aurais voulu avoir vosre
sentiments sur trois trois trois trois
interrogations la première euh dès lors
queon intègre la notion de droit droit à
mourir dans la dignité ou droit à une
fin de vie digne et apaisée j'ai
toujours la question c'est de dire
quelle est la relation lorsque des
patients n'auront pas forcément le
sentiment d'avoir un droit respecté
c'est-à-dire c'est tout la discussion
entre la personne malade et le médecin
entre la famille et le médecin qui dit
droit dit forcément à un moment donné
capacité de considérer si le droit est
appliqué correctement ou non et
forcément à travers ça pénalisation ou
sanction donc c'est une question
d'interrogation autour de cet aspect- là
deuxième inquiétude vous l'avez très
bien dit tout à l'heure en
parallèle il est nécessaire de
développer tout le volet autour des
soins palliatifs la formation alors
c'est un engagement qui a été pris par
le le président de la République vous
avez évoqué cela il a pris beaucoup
d'engagement pour l'instant les textes
que nous avons vécu depuis quelques mois
sur le vieillissement des populations
sur la loi santé je ne suis pas persuadé
aujourd'hui que les moyens notamment les
moyens financiers soit inscrit
réellement dans la capacité à développer
les soix palliatifs en France donc mon
inquiétude c'est de dire aujourd'hui on
a une réponse à une problématique que
vous présentez mais est-ce que
réellement au-delà des intentions on a
cette vraie capacité de développer les
soins palliatifs autrement dit est-ce
que c'est pas aussi une réponse par
rapport à un manque de moyens par
rapport au développement des soins
palliatifs aujourd'hui en France et
trisème point très naturellement vous
pouvez on peut très bien imaginer que à
travers l'évolution moi j'étais plutôt
un partisan de la loi de 2005 donc je je
considère que il y avait déjà beaucoup
d'avancé dans cette loi je peux
comprendre aujourd'hui que des
interrogations des inquiétudes
apparaissent entre la loi de 2005 cette
évolution et le ré déébat sur
l'eutthanasie donc je comprends que ces
questions inégration en tous les cas
puissent évoqué et donc je regrette que
clairement on n'écrive pas dans le
document que ce n'est pas une loi sur
l'eutthanasie aujourd'hui
voilà merci Monsieur Barbier Gilbert
oui merci monsieur le Président je crois
qu'effectivement le la première question
la première interrogation c'est de
savoir s'il était utile de légiférer à
nouveau parce que on l'a bien montré il
y a une loi de 2005 qui malheureusement
n'a pas connu une application suffisante
ça a été démontré partout et compris
dans les épades est-ce qu'il valaient
pas mieux rechercher des
moyens bien sûr financiers et de
formation
notamment des des personnels soignants
et notamment des médecins à cette à ces
soin palliatifs qui à mon avis n'a pas
beaucoup bougé dans les facultés ou dans
les écoles de formation de de de
personnel surant parce que en vouloir en
voulant légiférer à nouveau bien entendu
on essaie de de combler comme ça vient
d'être dit un certain nombre peut-être
de lacune du texte bon on veut surtout
répondre à une demande un engagement du
Président de la République bon ben c'est
bien il faut voir aussi que on est
poussé il fautut pas éviter le fait que
il y a une évolution dans la société on
voit bien encore dans le cadre de la loi
santé publique qui qui est en cours
c'est qu'on veut que l'individu alors
c'est la loi de 2002 je comprends bien
on veut retirer encore une parcelle de
décision au corps médical ou au corps
soignant comme dans beaucoup de
textes qui qui viendront bon ça c'est
une appréciation alors ce texte vous
avez essayé de travailler d'une manière
très importante mais néanmoins on reste
dans ce domaine avec une subjectivité
que on rencontre à toutes les lignes de
votre projet de loi parce que comme
jean-ltil a souligné bien entendu on
peut pas faire une énumération mais
quand on parle apparaisse inutile ou
disproportionné apparaître c'est déjà
d'une certaines difficultés inutile vous
avez évoqué plus loin dans l'article 3
le inutilement la vie euh à quel moment
la vie devient-elle utile ou inutile
est-ce que c'est pas à partir de la
naissance ou finalement à quoi sert-ton
sur cette terre eu ou alors est-ce que
c'est à partir de l'âge de la retraite
où effectivement on on sent un sentiment
d'inutilité je crois que là on est dans
le le subjectif d'une manière très
important on le retrouve et là euh sur
sur la partie euh le problème de la la
sédation Jean Léonetti insisté sur
sédation profonde et continue alors moi
je ne suis pas anesthésiste je ne sais
pas je sais pas
mais est-ce que le terme sédation
profonde est véritablement nécessaire
est-ce qu'une sédation n'entraîne pas
surtout si on se pas se pose à un stade
de terminal est-ce que quel est l'apport
de mettre ce terme profonde dans
l'affaire surtout que on y ajoute une
analgésie alors moi je je commence à se
dire sédation profonde analgésie plus
arrêt des traitements en cours
hydratation et cetera on pourrait
peut-être résumer ce terme en ce qui
vient d'être évoqué en euthanasie parce
que c'est c'est pratiquement euh si on
fait la synthèse de ce de de ce
traitement misise en place je crois qu'
on n pas loin de le asie sinon si on
veut est-ce que c'était l'intention de
masquer ce mot qui pour certains est
réclamé notamment par un certain nombre
d'associations et ça je crois que c'est
un débat très important euh subjectif
aussi court terme court terme où
commence le court terme où est le court
terme on a on a interrogé le professeur
Siard donc qui est venu devant les
rapporteurs lui il considère que ce
moment de l'agonie
l'agonie alors jean-léonettier évoqué
quelques heures quelques jours quelques
mois je ne sais pas le court terme il
faut le définir qu'est-ce qui est court
terme alors ça peut donner tout
interprétation possible c'est c'est très
difficile de pouvoir préciser d'une
manière dans la loi tous ces domaine et
là encore bien sûr il s'agira en
fonction de de laisser c'est les équip
équipe qui décideront si c'est du court
terme en fonction des affections enfin
on va pas faire c'est c'est très
difficile de pouvoir préciser où se
trouve le court terme voilà donc est-ce
que sur ces éléments sur ces ces termes
de court terme de profond de d'inutile
de
disproportionné je crois que là on est
quand même on reste quand même dans une
très grande difficulté et puis
euhiel l'a
évoqué c'est un peu l'expérience
personnelle le problème de la
néonatologie est certes quelque chose
mais il y a tout problème de l'enfant
mineur atteint d'une affection grave et
mortelle et là bien entendu la loi ne
peut pas intervenir c'est-à-dire qu'on
passe c'est pour montrer que bien
entendu c'est très difficile de
légiférer sur ce mais quand vous avez un
enfant atteint d'un concer du du cerveau
de 6 ou 7 ans avec une évolution dont on
s'est fatal euh comment
reprocher un acharnement thérapeutique
ou pas qui décide comment la la loi et
c'est bien que la loi n'en parle pas
parce que ça laisse quand même à la
famille et au médecin de pouvoir décider
à un moment donné ce qu'il y a lieu de
faire ça montre bien le le la difficulté
de légiférer dans ce domaine et
personnellement je pensais que le texte
2005 bien appliqué aurait permis
d'éviter de rouvrir un débat si ce n'est
de vouloir REP parler idéologie en
général sur ce texte madame Génisson
oui c'est c'est difficile de
d'intervenir dans c moi je voudrais
dire à la fois Alain Cless
et et Jean ont indiquer qu'il y avait on
a un problème culturel profond par
rapport dans la relation que nous avons
à la mort aujourd'hui et dans la mission
qui avait précédé l'écriture de la
proposition loi que nous avons faite ça
avait été montré de façon très
importante il y a aujourd'hui à la fois
une confrontation à la violence de la
mort qui est permanente et qui est très
agressive et en même temps un dénis de
la mort qui fait
que non seulement 51 51 % des personnes
meurtent aux urgences mais 70 % et même
plus meurent à l'hôpital donc on éjecte
on élimine la mort de de de de sa vie
quotidienne et même maintenant on peut
constater quand on regarde les les faire
part d'annonce de décès que y compris
les morts ne retournent pas chez eux ils
vont dans des salons funéraires moi je
me souviens que à la fin enfin au début
de l'exercice de la médecine on nous
suppliait de transporter de trouver tous
les moyens possibles imaginables pour
renvoyer le la personne qui était
quelquefois quasiment décédée dans sa
famille et chez elle il y a vraiment et
et au-delà de bien évidemment de la
nécessité de de comment dire
sensibiliser les les professionnels de
santé au sujet de des soins palliatifs
et de l' l'accompagnement d'une fin de
vie digne je pense que le le le sujet
est philosophiquement culturel beaucoup
plus profond et qu'on a à nous
interroger chacun d'entre nous sur la
façon dont on accompagne la mort de la
mort de de ses proches je crois que le
sujet est très profond
euh par rapport à et je crois que ça
correspond c'est un des arguments qui
qui qui fait que au-delà du manque de de
formation des professionnels de santé
sur le les soins palliatifs il y a cette
enfin c'est ce constat vis-à-vis de la
société de la société française
d'ailleurs aussiin particulièrement et
et qui fait que quand je pense que par
ailleurs la proposition de loi avait été
quand même excessivement bien travaillé
bien préparé puisqu'on avait eu plus
d'un an de de mission et qu'elle avait
été quand même votée à l'unanimité parce
que il y avait une volonté de faire des
propositions concrètes sur le sujet
majeur qui est quand même l'
l'accompagnement de la fin digne de de
chacun de chacune d'entre nous et moi
c'est par
rapport au texte qui a été voté en 2005
et qui manifestement nécessitait comment
dire une poursuite puisque il est mal
appliqué je crois qu'il y a
effectivement une mauvaise connaissance
de la loi y compris d'ailleurs par les
professionnel de santé en vous écoutant
l'un et l'autre et en souhaitant de
d'être plus efficace sur
l'accompagnement de la fin digne de pour
chacun d'entre nous je me dis que tout
ce qui était apporté
dans le texte peut finalement apporter
de la
complexité et peut-être n'est pas ne pas
être si efficace que cela en vous
écoutant si vous voulez et en
particulier je crois que le sujet des
des directives anticipées va être un
sujet de grande confrontation avec ça
dire la décision finale et l'acte que
pratique le médecin et je pense que la
proposition qui a été faite de parler de
procédure collégiale pour arriver à la
décision qu'appliquera que prendra le
médecin et la PR que de l'acte que fera
le médecin est tout à fait est tout à
fait
fondamental je pense en plus que quand
on parle de sédation profonde c'est pas
du tout la même chose qu'une sédation
une sédation on peut vivre 30 ans en
étant sédaté hein je crois que le le là
ce qui est apporté de de façon concrète
et là c'est peut-être l'anesthésiste qui
parle effectivement sédation profonde
plus un algésique plus arrêt de tout
traitement y compris de l'hydratation et
de la de la alimentation sont des
facteurs qui vont permettre d'arriver
rapidement à la fundingne pour chacun
d'entre nous
euh alors effectivement là aussi il y a
euh il y a un espace d'interrogation
dans la mesure où on sait que ça peut
durer finalement ça peut être un acte
qui peut entraîner la l'issue finale en
10 minutes qui peut l'entraîner en en en
2 TR jours et et c'est là qu'il y a
encore peut-être des interrogations
enfin moi si vous voulez c'est un texte
sur lequel bien évidemment j'ai
travaillé avec beaucoup d'intérêt et
beaucoup d'importance parce que je crois
que c'est un sujet qui nous concerne
fondamentalement mais bien évidemment
pas seulement bien les professionnels de
santé mais j'ai envie de dire que nous
en tant que citoyens nous avons aussi à
réfléchir beaucoup plus largement que
l'application d'un texte de loi sur ce
que représente l'accompagnement de la
Fing pour chacun d'entre nous et
peut-être les comportements différents
qu'on pourrait avoir vis-à-vis de ses
proches et vis-à-vis effec celles et
ceux qui nous entourent merci Monsieur
sigoloti
oui monsieur le Président messieurs déjà
merci de la clarté de de vos propos pour
des membres de cette commission qui ne
sont pas médecins effectivement vous
avez d'ors et déjà répondu à un certain
nombre d'interrogations que nous aurions
pu avoir on a bien senti également à
travers ces éléments que vous avez d'ors
et déjà pesé chaque mot et que pour vous
chaque mot a un sens et un sens très
précis dans le cadre de cette
proposition de loi il existe pour moi
une une inquiétude en matière de
d'inégalité territoriale vous l'avez
évoqué messieurs le rapport SICAR
précise que l'on meurt encore dans de
mauvaises conditions en France euh
monsieur Leonetti l'a évoqué
effectivement en balayant un peu les
amendements quel pourrait être pour vous
aujourd'hui les les propositions qui
pourraient être faites non pas pour
supprimer mais peut-être pour réduire
ces inégalités territoriales euh afin de
permettre que l'on puisse mourir dans de
meilleures conditions quel que soit le
territoire sur lequel on se trouve
aujourd'hui merci Monsieur cadiic
oui je vais me joindre donc
effectivement au remerciement de de mon
collègue pour pour ce travail euh pour
le caractère mesuré justement de de vos
propos euh mais surtout pour la sérénité
euh donc avec laquelle vous appréhendez
cette situation et eu qui est très
importante
alors est-ce que cette loi ou cette
proposition de loi est
utile moi j'en suis convaincu par
rapport d'autant plus après vous avoir
écouté clairement
euh est-ce qu'elle est
satisfaisante non et ça je voudrais vous
expliquer un petit peu effectivement mon
mon point de vue mon ressenti même si ce
sera certainement une redite pour vous
puisque effectivement on ne traite pas
d'une question qui est aujourd'hui
fondamentale pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens qui est effectivement ce
droit à mourir qui
est
attendu pour mes parents lorsque ils
étaient jeunes on m a beaucoup parlé de
cette génération qui était obligé de
partir en Angleterre pour avorter parce
que l'IVG n'était pas autorisé ici en
France aujourd'hui les gens partent euh
dans d'autres pays pour mourir parce
qu'ils l'ont décidé parce que c'est
inéluctable et malheureusement on a des
difficultés pour parler de cette réalité
et on permet pas vraiment à la
population de se confronter à sa fin de
vie et de faire ses choix en libre
conscience la liberté trouve toujours
son chemin et ce matin tout à l'heure
juste avant notre entretien j'ai appelé
une amie qui va
dans quelques jours et et j'ai voulu
discuter avec elle de cette audition
qu'on allait avoir
ensemble pour savoir un peu comment elle
elle ressentait les choses est ce
qu'elle avait envie de me faire passer
comme message c'est une
amie et donc elle m'a dit
qu'effectivement elle trouvait que
c'était ben regrettable aujourd'hui de
devoir
s'expatrier que c'était une forme un peu
de effectivement de violence de devoir
le quand même le
faire et que
euh cette cette décision c'était quand
même
pour pour avoir une fin de vie apaisée
qui était qui était importante pour elle
euh à partir du moment où on sait que la
la maladie est incurable puisqueaprès la
question c'est pas effectivement de dire
et je comprends votre votre question sur
le le fait le le temps que cela va
prendre
mais à partir du moment où on sait que
la maladie est incurable on rentre dans
l'accompagnement donc on sait que c'est
c'est inéluctable donc ça va se passer
alors maintenant vous avez parlé avec
beaucoup d'humanité de cette question de
ces de jours 3 jours parce que là on est
vraiment à la fin du
fin mais pour elle c'est pas c'est pas
acceptable de de voir attendre c'est
beaucoup trop tard et arver à cette
situation c'est une situation de
dégradation physique phique qui est une
violence pour elle mais aussi pour ses
proches que ses proches vont l'avir se
dégrader et se retrouver dans la
situation que vous vous essayez de de
régler aujourd'hui et ça bah elle ne le
souhaite pas elle ne veut pas de ses
soins palliatifs elle ne veut pas
arriver à cette situation là et donc
donc c'est ce qu'elle m'a dit et et
c'est c'est son
message c'est ça c'est de qu'on prenne
ça en compte que ça serait un vrai
progrès si on le prenait en compte alors
tout ça pour pour vous dire
qu'effectivement par rapport à votre vos
travaux et par rapport aux questions que
certains se posent est-ce que c'est
utile oui vraiment moi je suis très fier
d'être à vos côté aujourd'hui pour vous
accompagner dans ce que vous avez fait
parce que c'est important pour beaucoup
de gens vous répondez à une une vraie
attente aujourd'hui je pense vous
essayez de le faire de la meilleure
façon qui soit so donc moi je seraiis
évidemment bien évidemment à vos côtés
pour pour pour soutenir ce que vous
faites mais encore une fois est-ce que
c'est satisfaisant non à mes yeux on ne
répond pas une une vraie attente et on
est là pour faire une loi qui répond
vraiment à l'attente des citoyens et ce
que j'aimerais de de votre part
peut-être c'est savoir quels seraient
vos
préconisation pour entrer de manière
apaisée justement dans un débat qui
permettrait de à notre société de
débattre de façon apaisée de ce droit à
mourir voilà merci
beaucoup merci Monsieur
Chassin monsieur le Président tout
d'abord je voudrais aussi moi dire que
je suis reconnaissant effectivement à à
Monsieur CLA et à Monsieur
Leonetti d'avoir bien voulu ce matin
venir pour nous faire ver cet exposé
extrêmement précis
et nous avons pu voir que connaît
absolument ils connaissent absolument
bien leur leur dossier alors je viens
d'entendre monsieur Cadix qui nous a
fait un
témoignage à fort de son ami mais je
voudrais dire que effectivement ce ce
caslà c'est un cas qu'il faut prendre en
compte mais la la mort l'accompagnement
de la mort est chaque fois particulier
et donc moi je peux témoigner un petit
peu de de l'expérience que j'ai de de
médecin rural euh je dois dire que au
niveau des épades euh ben j'ai pas
l'expérience que vous avez puisque moi
depuis plusieurs années je fais appel
aux soins palliatifs
euh donc je j'ai le le CHR de Tul qui
qui vient c'est pas récent c'est depuis
plusieurs années à ma demande et si j'ai
besoin de bah de de conseil j'appelle le
responsable du bon du service
donc pour l'instant si vous voulez ça se
passe comme ça dans le dans en tout cas
dans le secteur où je suis en ce qui
concerne le le dimanche et les jours les
jours fériers le samedi effectivement
jusqu'à il y a 3 ans et bien on était de
garde 24h sur 24 mais depuis efftivent
la permanence de soin euh les médecins
ne souhaitent plus prendre de garde de
nuit donc on est obligé d'avoir un
secteur très important et donc j'en
reviens à ce que j'avais dit à Madame le
Ministre de la Santé pour remplacer un
médecin tel qu'on l'a été maintenant il
en faudrait plusieurs donc enfin au
moins deux donc je pense que il faut
élargir le numérus clusus si on veut
qu'il ait encore des médecins en en
campagne mais bon ça c'est notre débat
en ce qui en ce qui me concerne donc euh
je je pense que la loi telle qu'elle
existait pour moi c'était un un progrès
très important
euh alors il faudrait effectivement
c'est ce qu'a dit tout à l'heure nos
collègues avoir des moyens dans dans
tous les les
CHR pour avoir des équipes de soins
palliatifs et enseigner davantage les
soins palliatifs au niveau des des
facultés et et je rejoins un peu ce qu'a
dit Madame
Génisson cette c'est bien d'aller encore
plus loin pour savoir quand est-ce qu'on
on met la la sédation mais ça appte bien
sûr un peu de complexité donc je ai cité
bon de de cas que j'ai eu très récemment
c'est une dame qui a une certaine
démence qui ben depuis le
Vendredi elle déjà elle s'alimentait pas
bien elle était déshydratée donc je l'ai
vu le lundi matin elle était déshydratée
avec des troubles de la conscience je
lui ai mis simplement une perfusion et
je faire un ionogramme donc il fallait
l'hydrater uniquement en intravineneux
ou en ou en souscutané avec du glucosé
donc c'était pas de l'acharnement la
famille m'avait dit donc maintenant il
faut abréger les bah les choses puis bon
ben au bout de 2 jours elle était mieux
les constantes sont revenue normal et
puis maintenant elle est toujours là
elle s'alimente alors voilà qu'est-ce
qu'il fallaitire faire à ce moment-là
euh donc ensuite j'ai eu un ami qui a
été qui a eu une gastrectomie pour un
cancer de de de de l'entrée de
l'estomac bon il il y a eu beaucoup de
problèmes pour la réalimentation il
voulait plus qu'on le réalimente on l'a
quand même fait de façon agressive et il
est au bout de plusieurs mois il a
réussi à se réalimenter et il voulait
donc à ce moment-là qu'on qu'on arrête
sa sa vie et il a été opéré dans 5 ans
après d'un cancer de l'intestin il est
encore en vie donc voilà c'est chaque
cas est est un cas particulier et moi en
tout cas dans ce que vous avez dit je
reprendrai
surtout la décision collégiale avec la
mort doit être
imminente et la souffrance du malade
réfractaire à tout traitement habituel
avant la mise en place d'une sédation
profonde jusqu'au décès merci bien
monsieur cl et Leonetti vous avez la
parole très
rapidement je crois qu'à travers vos
interventions chers collègues on
retrouve l'ensemble des éléments qui ont
fait l'objet
de du débat à l'Assemblée cèg mouiller
dit qu'il n'est pas médecin je ne suis
pas non
plus donc je suis toujours en formation
continue je crois que
euh le
sujet de scène qui existe ce sont les
inégalités territoriales je crois que
collègue sigolotti l'a
évoqué si on ne réduit pas ces
inégalités
territorial j'allis dire on ne
euh on ne réglera aucun des problèmes et
donc là ce sont euh véritablement des
moyens financiers qui sont en jeu et moi
je vais vous répondre très franchement
que ça soit les précédents gouvernements
cel-ci il faut vraiment changer de
braquet et que sur les
soin
palliatif il puisse y avoir un
développement j'aiévoqué en introduction
tout début y compris dans les CHU la
clification par l'activité il y a des
mesures à prendre
le deuxième élément et notre collègue M
l'a évoqué d'autres l'ont évoqué c'est
la formation alors je voudrais vous dire
c'est sur ce sujet-là la formation que
le Président de la République a pris des
engagements il n pas pris des engagement
uniquement par une déclaration
d'intention il y a actuellement entre le
ministère de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche et la conférence des
doyens des travaux qui ont lieu et ça
devrait aboutir par des propositions de
formation dans le cycle de formation des
médecins à la rentrée 2015 2000 201
2016 je crois que
c'est Monsieur notre collègue barbier
qui a évoqué pourquoi profonde c'est
l'tion profonde j'ai pas peut-être
prolonger le débat Jean avait répondu
tout à l'heure mais je crois que votre
collègue Génisson l'a évoqué aussi cette
sédation profonde et continu
d'expression nous l'avons pas inventé
elle repose sur quelque chose
médicalement reconnu
aujourd'hui
sur le débat euh sur le débat
euh est-ce que c'est une loi
euh cè mouillé de la poser à la fin
écrivez que c'est pas une loi pour
euthanasie et
notre
collègue cardic cardic a dit ce que je
vous reproche c'est de pas franchir le
pas hein donc à travers vos deux
interventions vous voyez le chemin qu'on
a essayé
d'utiler nous nous ne reconnaissons pas
dans cette loi
l'euthanasie c'est très clair et on a eu
ce débat à l'Assemblée nationale et
j'ajoute
aussi que nous réglerons nous réglons
pas l'ensemble des cas quand vous
relisez la lettre de mission du Premier
ministre elle est extrêmement précise
nous sommes en fin de vie pronostic
vital est
engagé et puis il y a une autre chose
moi je
respecte
beaucoup les collègues qui
défendent
l'euthanasie et par rapport au sujet qui
nous préoccupe aujourd'hui et à la
double
préoccupation de nos concitoyens qu'on
pourrait résumer ainsi nous voulons être
entendus et nous voulons avoir une fin
de vie apaisée entouré nos
proches par rapport à ces demandes par
rapport à l'inégalité qui existe sur le
territoire est-ce que que notre
société doit répondre en disant la
solution c'est un acte
létal je ne le pense pas aujourd'hui je
ne le pense pas je pense qu'aujourd'hui
nous devons prendre à bras LEC les
sujets les sujets sur lesquels nous
sommes interpellés et quand je vois les
sondages on parle souvent de
sondage notre proposition c'est lation
profond etc continu 98 % des des
Français ils sont ils sont favorables
euthanasie monanasie 90 % mais qu'est-ce
que nous disent les Français à travers
son je suis pas convaincu que ils
mettent des choses très précises à
travers euthanasie il ne disent
simplement quelque chose au législateur
à mon sens dis si vous êtes pas
capable de nous assurer une une fin de
vie notre dernière partie de la vie de
façon apaisée et digne alors nous
prendrons notre dessin en main et nous
prendrons ces actultives je crois que
c'est cette interpellation et je pense
que c'est à cette interpellation
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui que nous devons
répondre moi je crois que c'est ma
propre conviction hein on a eu ce débat
à l'Assemblée nationale ça a duré une
partie de de l'après-midi ce débat est
respectable et ce dont je me félicite
c'est que ce débat c'est'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est pas toujours
le cas à l'Assemblée nationale on est
moins sage que vous mais ça s'est passé
de façon très calme et très respectueux
il n'y a pas eu il n'y a pas eu apaisé
il y a pas eu il y a pas eu un moment de
de de parole déplacé ou de dérapage euh
je crois que c'est je terminerai par là
euh à notre collègue Barbier
euh j'ai pas le sentiment je suis pas
médecin je vous le rappelle qu'on retire
du pouvoir au corps médical je n'ai pas
ce
sentiment-l je pense que
euh alors j'ai eu des ces discussions
avec jeanléonétiique et médecin et qui
mieux qui compte connaît l'évolution du
corps médical je crois que au f à mesure
que les techniques
médicales progressent au fur à mesure
que les capacités de diagnostique
progressent il faudrait pas que la
relation entre le médecin et le patient
s'éloigne s filoch et c'est pas parce
que vous donnez de nouveaux droits au
patient que le pouvoir du médecin est
affaibli je ne pense absolument pas je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on parle souvent à
tort et parfois de très mal de médecine
personnalisée à un moment où on est
capable de découper en tranche pour
analyser le corps de malade avec des
techniques de plus en plus sophistiquées
pour moi une médecine personnalisé c'est
des droits des uns et des autres pour le
bien au bout du compte du patient donc
je ne pense pas qu'on retire du pouvoir
au euh au au au médecin
je pas aller plus loin il il y a des
points que je n'ai pas évoqué que j'en
va évoquer mais voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire brement en vous remerciant de
l'ensemble des sujets que vous évoquez
parce que c'est l'ensemble des sujets du
débat je vais essayer de de pas
reprendre ce que dit
anangla ça devient inquiétant parce que
euh il dis ce que je pense et donc c'est
c'est cette cette
fusion et est très inquiétante à titre
personnel et même sur le plan politique
mais
bon sur un sujet
particulier je crois que ce qui est
important c'est que je l'ai bien senti
dans vos
interrogations c'est que nous avons des
interrogations et tant que sur ces
sujets nous n'affronterons pas les
certitudes individuelles des HES par
rapport aux autres et que nous aurons
des doutes collectifs je pense que nous
aurons effectivement une situation dans
laquelle la remarque des uns apparaîtra
comme un élément positif même lorsque
elle ne va pas obligatoirement dans le
sens de ce que nos convictions nous
portent à penser je voudrais redire à
Monsieur sénateur mouiller
qu'effectivement plus encore que des
moyens en soin palliatif plus encore que
des moyens développés par la RS il faut
qu'il y ait une double culture qui se
développe une culture d'une médecine
nouvelle euh
et plus attentive à ne pas avoir comme
obsession de de de ne vaincre que la
mort et et et plus attentive à à à
soulager et accompagner ou du moins
aussi attentive à soulager accompagner
qu'à guérir et à sauver et que cette
culture elle doit aussi être une
nouvelle culture de nos
concitoyens Catherine Génisson et é à
juste
titre au fond le scandale de la mort
qu'évoque le philosophe jankelevic mais
aussi le dénis de mort qui est profond
dans cette société attention à ne pas
faire en sorte qu'un jour la mort soit
régé par des protocoles
médicaux et que la médicalisation de la
mort n'aggrave pas le dénis de notre
finitude qui est complètement
occultée je partage ce que disait
Catherine Génisson tout à l'heure vécu
moi aussi une médecine dans laquelle on
rentrait chez soi pour mourir et
maintenant on vient à l'hôpital pour
mourir c'est quand même très
significatif et et dans une certaine
forme une confiance dans la médecine qui
à la fois sauve et soulage mais aussi
inquiétant quant à la ou à la perte du
caractère familier et familial et humain
de de de la fin de la vie alors c'est
pas une loi sur le faut-il le dire
euh j'ai bien compris que certains le
déplorent et et certains s'en inquiètent
en tout cas ce que je peux dire c'est
que le texte qui nous présentons avec
Alain Clais n'est pas une euthanasie
déguisée et s'il fallait le s'il fallait
le prouver et pour convaincre mon ami le
sénateur Barbier je dirais que
euh c'est pas les mêmes médicaments qui
tuent et les médicaments qui soulagent
et et pour arriver à à obtenir le décès
de quelqu'un en utilisant des
médicaments comme des sédatifs ou des
antalgiques ou des analgésique il faut
utiliser des très très très très fortes
doses
euh les médecins le savent bien le le
curard et le chloron de potassium
arrêtent la vie l'hypnovel et la
morphine n'atteignent pas cet objectif
alors est-ce que le lâcherprise doit
être accepté ce que les soins palliatifs
appellent le lâcher prise ce moment où à
la fois on a le sentiment qu'on est au
bout du chemin et qu'on veut surtout pas
être j'allais dire inutilement
prolongé
prolongé artificiellement abusivement et
où en même temps on
veut dormir avant de mourir pour ne pas
souffrir je vous rappellerai quand même
que nos concitoyens quand on leur
demande qu'est-ce que c'est que la bonne
mort et finalement si s'ils étaient
Grecs qui diraient qu'est-ce que c'est
que l'euthanasie qui ne veut jamais dire
qu'autre chose que la bonne mort B ils
disent que c'est dormir et ne pas se
réveiller et donc là peut-être c'est un
texte qui répond à une idée généralement
admise que entre la mort dans l'agonie
douloureuse d'un côté où la mort brutale
il y a la mort peut-être apaisée qui est
de s'endormir et de ne pas se réveiller
je dis pas que c'est l'objectif de ce
texte mais en tout cas s'il y a une
correspondance dans les sondages aussi
fortes et et et quelquefois des
interrogations parce que lorsque
j'explique et vous devez vivre la même
chose à l'extérieur que on va dormir
qu'on va arrêter les traitements puis
qu'on va partir de manière apaisée
entouré par sa famille en
dormant il y a beaucoup de gens qui me
disent mais c'est lethanasie et
dernièrement dans une intervention et
une personne qui a pris la parole et qui
m'a dit mais
euh je suis
partisan de l'euthanasie mais ce que
vous proposez c'est l'euthanasie je lui
ai dit l'euthanasie non elle a une
définition hein c'est la mort donnée
volontairement par un malade qui le
réclame par un généralement par un
médecin qui qui le qui
l'exécute donc on se trouve dans dans
une situation qui est différente mais
regardez comment le mot euthanasie a
dérivé d'une situation qui était le non
acharnement thérapeutique regardez bacon
hein les premièr définitions c'est bien
ça ne vous acharnez pas et ne me laissez
pas souffrir c'était ça initialement le
thelasi et puis aujourd'hui c'est la
mort volontaire et qui pose d'autres
problèmes à la fois philosophiques et
juridiquees je voudrais rappeler à à mon
collègue et sénateur Barbier que les
traitements qui apparaissent inutiles ou
disproportionnés c'est la Loet de 2005
et qu'elle était flou oui alors on peut
reprocher un texte d'être flou mais on
peut aussi se réjouir qu'il soit pas
tatillon qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
traitement inutile ça se définit en
circonstance et en au cas par cas
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un traitement
disproportionné ça se définit en
circonstance et au cas par cas et au
fond la loi de 2005 si on devait la
définir elle dit trois choses elle dit
elle parle comme un médecin et c'est un
devoir du corps médical au travers d'un
devoir de société qui dit je
t'abandonnerai pas je te laisserai pas
souffrir et je te prolongerai pas de
manière normale et on voit bien que
c'est une loi comme le disait alin clè
de devoir de la société envers les
vulnérables envers les plus vulnérables
et là c'est une loi qui dit
euh j'exige de ne pas souffrir en fin de
vie et c'est le malade qui parle et donc
on est passé d'un droit d'un devoir
d'une société envers les plus
vulnérables à un regain légitime de
l'autonomie et de la liberté du patient
qui dit j'exige de ne pas souffrir en en
fin de vie est-ce queun droit qui
s'oppose qui s'adosse à un devoir est en
contradiction avec le devoir non j'ai le
devoir en tant que médecin de pas
laisser souffrir quelqu'un en fin de vie
il a le droit de me
demander de faire mon devoir et donc il
y a pas de véritable antagonisme il y a
au contraire une cohérence entre entre
l'un et et entre l'autre je reviens pas
sur profonde cari Génisson a répondu et
sur le court terme qu'est-ce que c'est
que la fin de
vie nous sommes tous en fin de
vie al minon disait que lorsqu'il
mettait un bébé sur le ventre de sa mère
il disait voilà voilà que vient de
naître un mortel voilà effectivement
nous sommes tous en fin de vie donc
Confucius dit une phrase qui mpelle
beaucoup qui dit nous avons tous deux
vies la deuxième commence quand on se
rend compte qu'on en a qu'une
et c'est peut-être bien ça en fait c'est
l'annonce de la maladie grave l'âge
avancé qui nous fait dire tiens un jour
un jour je partirai un jour je mourrai
et donc cette situation là est
totalement occultée dans notre société
et pose un vrai problème dans la
performance qu'on demande à la médecine
à la fois d'assurer une mort sans
souffrance qui n'existe pas parce que la
mort c'est au moins les larmes de
l'arrachement
le scandale qu'évoquait
yankelevic cette incompréhension face à
l'absurdité de la vie au néant de la
mort et qui pose évidemment le problème
existentiel essentiel de de l'humain
depuis qu'il est homme et qu'il enterre
ses morts et qu'il dessine des des sur
les sur les abris qu'il vient découvrir
donc c'est un problème qu'on résoudra
pas par un texte ce texte a la modestie
de dire on va va essayer de pas de faire
la bonne mort pour tout le monde la mort
sereine
apaisée digne et cetera on va essayer
simplement de garantir à nos concitoyens
que dans les derniers temps de leur vie
ils n'auront pas une souffrance subie et
qui sera face à une indifférence d'un
monde médical mal formé pour aborder ce
ce problème réduire les ingalité
territoriale monsieur le sénateur vous
avez raison peut-être que il faudra
quand même que cette culture se
développe aussi et c'est pour ça
l'amendement sur les ARS a été adopté
avec cette idée est-ce que l'ARS est
capable les ARS sont capables de
dééfinir sur l'ensemble d'un territoire
comment on répond à ça je voudrais
aussi poser le problème du droit à la
mort c'est un sujet je regrette que ce
sujet est occulté tout les autres sujets
beaucoup plus larges mais c'est un
sujet j'ai pas de répon réponse
spécifique il y a la jurisprudence Préti
il y a toute une série de réflexions
là-dessus mais au fond nous sommes
plutôt bien ensemble mais chacun d'entre
nous en sortant peut se donner la mort
et depuis
1792 les hommes sont libres de se
suicider libre droit liberté
euh ça veut bien dire que ce droit-là et
si je le traduis euh de manière laïque
et républicaine ça veut dire que la vie
appartient aux hommes la vie
n'appartient pas à Dieu et que la foi
est un est un élément qui est euh
indépendant dans l'idée que euh ce
donner la mort puisse être un acte un
homicide contre soi-même puisse être
incriminé on peut même se poser la
question et Badinter le faisait
intelligemment est-ce que un acte qui
n'est pas incriminable peut-être aidé et
s'il est dtad pourquoi serait-il
incriminable et c'est pas loin de ce qui
est décidé en Suisse où dès l'instant où
l'aide au suicide dès l'instant où il
n'est pas égoïste selon le terme Suisse
apparaît comme légitime mais vous le
savez aussi le débat sur la fin de vie
et sur le droit à la mort est un débat
entre l'autonomie et la vulnérabilité
est-ce que je j'écoute l'autonomie si
j'écoute l'autonomie à 100 % je ne
réanime pas le suicider qui a décidé de
mourir et si je n'écoute que la
vulnérabilité je décide de tout à la
place de celui qui est vulnérable au au
nom d'une autorité que je que je moque
trois à sa place dans cet équilibre
difficile à trouver le droit à la mort
est un droit créance deviendrait un gros
droit créance or les droits créan il y
en a pas beaucoup hein le droit à la vie
c'est un droit créance j'ai le droit de
demander à la société de protéger ma vie
mais si vous lisez la jurisprudence
Préti ou d'autres j'ai pas le droit de
demander à la société de me donner la
mort parce que si chacun d'entre nous là
peut partir et se jeter dans la scène
parce qu'il estime que sa vie vaut pas
la peine d'être vécu et après tout c'est
son droit et son choix et sa mort lui
appartient en revanche il n'a pas le
droit de demander à ses collègues de
l'aider à le faire et il ne le ferait
pas justement parce qu'il considérerait
que la vulnérabilité dans cette
situationl est plus doit être mise en
exerg par rapport à l'autonomie le débat
est sera jamais achevé
voilà je ne suis pas sûr que on puisse
en revanche si vous me le permettez
faire la comparaison avec l'IVG parce
que je dirais
que l'IVG c'est une situation dans
laquelle les femmes et et die sais si ma
génération l'a vécu mettait leur vie en
danger justement parce qu'ell avorter et
que on peut toujours essayer de regarder
dans les équilibres éthiques choses mais
en tout cas dans cet équilibre là on a
sauvé des vies humaines euh peut-être
euh au au prix de de d'élimination de de
de de potentialité de vie à venir hein
ou de personnes en devenir mais en tout
cas il y avait un débat dans lequel on
savait que la mort justement de ces
femmes jeunes existait et que c'était un
scandale de se trouver dans dans ces
situationsl parce que rien n'a empêché
les femmes d'abord d'aborter voilà et
quand vous regardez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans certains pays du
Maghreb c'est la même chose et
donc il y avait une mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui et et la loi veille a au
moins réparé cette cette cette
injustice je je note quand même deux
choses dans ce que vous avez dit
monsieur le sénateur et je suis assez
d'accord avec vous notre société demande
de ne pas se dégrader ce qui est un un
un nouveau un nouveau une nouvelle
nouvelle mission impossible comment je
fais pour pas me dégrader euh au fond il
faudrait que que si si on va au bout du
paradoxe c'est c'est mourir très tôt ou
mourir à l'annonce de la maladie et
d'ailleurs certains le demandent et
rappelez-vous ce prix Nobel qui parce
qu'il apprend qu'il a une début de
maladie
Alzheimer va au suicide il y a il y a là
une un véritable problème pour une
société qui à ce moment-là si elle
permettait cette situation là dirait au
plus vulnérable et et et oui votre mort
est légitime dès l'instant où vous
n'êtes pas jeune performant rentable
utile et là le mot reviendrait
effectivement et poserit un problème à
la société et puis ne pas attendre et ça
c'est un autre problème que nous
rencontrons en médecine et et dans la
société lorsque la mort est annoncée
elle doit
venir je dis pas ça comme une
affirmation je dis que ça comme un
ressenti de la part des familles et
quelquefois de la part des malades et ce
problème du temps est un problème qui va
poser
effectivement d'énores difficultés à la
gestion et c'est la raison pour laquelle
la sédation profonde ne peut pas être
mise en place sur des gens qui ont une
longue période de vie devant eux sinon
on va avoir des gens qui vont dormir et
où on va se poser la question mais
qu'est-ce qu'on est en train de faire
quel est le sens de l'action que l'on
mène donc effectivement je pense que on
est dans une loi qui dit ne pas souffrir
avec un changement de société qui est
majeur un changement de la médecine qui
est majeur passeun d'une médecine
paternaliste autoritaire mais en même
temps dévoué à une médecine qui va être
beaucoup plus juridique
euh peut-être toujours individuelle mais
qui en même temps va affronter
l'émergence de l'autonomie et de
l'individu face à des euh des règles
collectives qui seront toujours et de
plus en plus contester compte tenu de la
performance de la médecine actuelle en
tout cas je je vous remercie
profondément avec Alain CLIS de nous
avoir reçu euh tout à l'heure le
président disait je lui disais il faut
il faut répondre brièvement il me dit
non tu as tout le temps et maintenant il
vient de me faire comme
ça a compris que j' étais trop bavard
mais ce sujet vous le savez tous c'est
un sujet inépuisable et donc je vous
remercie de nous d'aboir eu la patience
de nous de nous écouter et d'avoir eu
ces échanges qui sont des échanges
indispensable et en étant sûr que le
Sénat va améliorer ce texte de manière
significative comme il sait toujours le
faire avec beaucoup de sagesse bien on
va remercier n nos collègues Alain Cless
et Jean Leonetti et leur dire que nous
avons beaucoup apprécié leurs
interventions et cette démarche de
sagesse qu'ils ont eu dans cette
proposition d'IT toute sénatoriale
finalement voilà pour cette audition sur
la fin de vie vous avez pu entendre Jean
Leonetti et Alain Clais revenir devant
les sénateurs sur leur propositions de
loi sur la fin de vie parmi les deux
mesures phares de ce texte je vous le
rappelle il y a les directives
anticipées qui permettent aux patients
de faire connaître à leurs médecins ou à
leurs proches la manière dont ils
souhaitent terminer leur vie et puis la
sédation profonde pour les malades en
phase terminale qui leur permet et bien
de mourir dans des conditions que les
députés jugent dignes le texte je vous
le rappelle a été adopté à l'Assemblée
nationale en première lecture le 10 7
mars dernier il doit arriver au Sénat
pour une première lecture mais il n'est
pas encore inscrit à l'agenda du Sénat
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
cette audition sur notre site
publsenat.fr dans quelques instants vous
avez rendez-vous avec Delphine gerérard
pour votre 24hur Sénat très bonne suite
des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires